hello everyone welcome to the december
2020 ask me anything edition of the
mindscape podcast i'm your host sean
carroll
as you probably know last month's ama
which is done for patreon supporters you
can always support
mindscape at patreon.com sean m carroll
patreon supporters get to uh ask
questions for the monthly ama
and they voted to release the answers to
the general public so
we sort of tentatively did that
half-heartedly a few months ago
on youtube um but it wasn't really quite
part of the regular podcast feed
last month was the first time we did it
for for real on the podcast feed
and so the good news is that got a few
more patreon supporters all of whom want
to ask ama questions which is great
so we have some new uh listeners here
and
this is the first this is the first
month where it'll be exactly the same
podcast being released the episode
including this
introductory part so hello everyone who
is a new supporter
and thank you to all the supporters that
we've had for a while
this is a great tradition we have and
also just so you know
uh we're not going to have a january
2021
ask me anything i take a couple of weeks
off from the whole podcast
thing for the end of december beginning
of january we all need to take a break
even
podcasters like myself so the next ama
will be i will put up the post asking
for
questions at the end of january and be
releasing the
episode in the beginning february so
hopefully all that makes
perfect sense anyway uh lots of
questions as you might expect
uh today because we have some new
listeners and askers of questions not
everyone knows the rules
the biggest rule being you only get one
question to ask okay so i know some
people ask more than one
if you if you do it's actually perfectly
okay to ask more than one question but
i'm
only going to answer one of the
questions any topic is okay but nothing
that requires me to do
work that might be read a paper watch a
video
read some document or anything like that
this is just an opportunity to get
information or opinions from my brain
without me doing any work
me doing no work is a is a very common
criterion for things i try to do in the
world
um what was the other thing anything
else oh yeah you know
the number of questions is large this
episode will be long
so to the extent possible try to aim for
concision
in one's asking of questions i do edit
the questions down but that takes time
for me
and you know everyone else wants to
listen to the answers to their questions
so
i know that there's a temptation to you
know tell a story
develop your characters have three act
structures with conflicts and
heartbreaks and points of no return
but the ama questions are best when
they're short and sweet and to the point
and you know most of them are but i'm
just
giving you a reminder that that's how it
successfully works
um otherwise yeah so here we are
beginning of december
hope everyone had a good thanksgiving if
you celebrate that good
uh hope hoping ahead of time that you
will have good winter holidays whatever
your favorite winter holiday
might be good news being that uh
we might have a vaccine i mean there's
good news because donald trump is not
going to be president anymore but
you all knew that the other good news is
that there might be vaccines coming for
coven 19.
the lockdown pandemic has
had its toll uh taken a toll on all of
us
myself included i've been as i'm very
happy to say
i suffer from the pandemic lockdown way
less
than most people do given my job etc but
still
you know ready to get out there ready to
travel again there's a lot of places i
would have visited this year
uh that i didn't including spending a
lot more time
in santa fe where i'm now an external
professor and talking to the people
there
um and so i hope that everyone listening
is doing more or less okay in the
pandemic and i'm hoping that
things will return mostly to normal i
know that people have talked a lot about
will it really be normal if we get a
vaccine and everyone's vaccinated
and maybe it won't be maybe everyone
will still be wearing masks maybe they
won't allow
concerts or bars or whatever i actually
am optimistic that we will get mostly
back to normal but as you know
especially if you've listened to
the podcast episodes we did with tara
smith and david baltimore
developing a vaccine for something like
this is very very tricky you know
testing it
figuring out that there's no terribly
deleterious side effects and so forth it
can take a long time i'm
i'm optimistic about the vaccines but uh
i'm sure that there will be snefus down
the road so it's hard to predict
exactly when it will go into wide scale
circulation but still
i think it's okay to be a little
optimistic we've been pessimistic for a
while things have been tough right now
here in la as well as the rest of the
united states certainly
we're in the middle of a wave again you
know i guess the third wave by now
we're locking down no more restaurants
anymore
anything like that here in la so
hopefully that will do a good job and
even before the vaccine uh
comes will be able to return somewhat to
normal anyway with all that
so many questions about the universe and
life and everything so
let's go
[Music]
sam barta says i've heard you say both
that in the many worlds interpretation
of quantum mechanics the observer and
detector are treated as quantum and at
other times that macroscopic objects are
treated classically due to decoherence
how can macroscopic objects be in
superpositions if their amplitudes are
spiked
due to being measured by the environment
can you please help me understand this
tension
and or my confusion sure it's just a
difference between
what you perceive on a single branch of
the wave function
versus what's going on in the
wavefunction of the universe the
collection of all the branches
considered together
so when a geiger counter goes off right
because it's measured some quantum
mechanical event whether or not
you are schrodinger's cat or just a
person carrying a geiger counter
that means that some little nucleus of
an atom
has its quantum state had become
entangled with the rest of the world
it is either decayed or not decayed and
so the world is branched in two but also
macroscopically
you heard the geiger counter go off and
therefore
you have branched into but you have to
change what you mean by the word
you there's now two different people one
of whom heard the geiger counter go off
one of whom didn't so when we say things
like
the person is a quantum system and
they're in a superposition that's
completely true
in the wave function of the universe
there's one person who heard the geiger
counter and responded appropriately and
one who didn't
but you can also say that a person is
localized spatially and in other quantum
mechanical variables
but that means on a single branch so
that's the thing about the emergence of
the classical limit
in quantum mechanics is that not only is
there branching
but that on individual branches physics
behaves
more or less classically so on
individual branches we expect
people and planets and things like that
to have more or less well-defined
locations in the universe more or less
well-defined
velocities up to some error but still
pretty well defined
and that's completely compatible with
the wave function of the universe
including superpositions where those
people are in very different
positions or velocities or whatever
rakesh patel says any tips on time
management
there are so many books podcast youtube
blog side project center have you found
a way to manage this
well you know i'm actually not someone
who is very formal
about these things you know when it
comes to productivity tips
time management tips things like that i
joke about it but honestly i don't have
much of a
system and partly that's because in the
kind of work that i do whether it's you
know solving equations or thinking about
physics or
writing or whatever that kind of work
you can't do it on demand you can't do
it on schedule right you know i i have
moments when i'm very inspired and i
want to do it and that you
you uh would have trouble tearing me
away from it
and other times where i'm sitting there
and i know that i should be doing some
writing or some physics or whatever and
it's just not coming right
so i find it almost impossible to plan
those things ahead of time you know
podcasting
you had to plan ahead of time you had to
actually make an appointment with
another person very annoying but
um you know that's also something i
could try to plan ahead for
um so no i do not have any tips on time
management
i just try to minimize the bad things
the distractions and
you know carve out room for everything
else but as i've said before
on the podcast and elsewhere i'm the
kind of person who likes to have a
million things going at once
in different areas so what works for me
is not necessarily going to work for
somebody else
sorry about that robert ruxin rescue
says
we know a black hole is a region of
space time where the entropy is very
high and gravity dominates
is there any mathematical reason why the
big bang universe
by the big bang slash the universe can't
be a white hole
it's actually very similar to a white
hole it's almost exactly the same with
one possible
difference so a white hole is just a
time
reversed version of a black hole so in a
black hole if you have like a star
collapsing or something like that
the star collapses its density increases
and also the metric that measures the
curvature of space time becomes singular
at a moment in the future of the black
hole which we call the singularity
and that's almost exactly the same as
what happens at the big bang
played in reverse at the big bang we
nominally start
with an infinite at least that's what
the equations say we don't really
believe it physically but we imagine
that there's
something taking the place of infinite
density and curvature that then expands
and dilutes
so that you get a more or less sensible
classical big
bang but the difference is that as far
as we know
the big bang was everywhere but the big
bang
event that moment uh of time
extended throughout the universe
everywhere in the universe again as far
as we know because we don't know for
sure but in the models that we play with
we imagine the big bang started all
throughout space
at whatever moment of time that was so
there's no such thing as
outside the big bang that's the
difference
between a white hole and the big bang a
white hole if you really literally take
it as a backwards
in time black hole has an inside and
outside right there's an event horizon
uh for a black hole the event horizon is
something you can go into but not come
out of
for the white hole the event horizon is
something you can go out of but not come
into
but there's still you imagine that there
is the white hole and there's something
called outside
the white hole and for the big bang as
far as we know there's no such thing
otherwise they're very very simple
similar christian dobo says as a
layperson i'm still not totally
convinced i understand what it means
that according to special relativity one
cannot talk about what is happening now
on kepler-452b what if the united
federation of planets were to designate
a zero coordinate in space time then
send ships with perfectly synchronized
clocks to numerous
planets and then it goes on from there
so the point is
sure you can absolutely lay out what we
would call
a reference frame in relativity special
relativity general relativity or
whatever
the the only claim on the part of
relativity is that there's nothing
special
about your reference frame if the united
federation of planets wants to lay out
one reference frame upon which we can
which we she can draw upon to talk about
what is happening at one moment
on this planet and some other planet
there's nothing to stop the klingons or
the romulans from laying out a
completely different
reference frame which is you know tilted
in the space time with respect to the
first one
so that's either one of those is
perfectly okay there's nothing in
special relativity it says we can't talk
about simultaneity
it's just that it's not objective it's
not universal it's not built into space
time itself
it's just a choice individual people
choose to make
stephen noble says have you considered
any guests who would talk to your
audience about advances
in programming languages i haven't
thought about that you know i have
thought about computer science in
different ways it's always a little bit
tricky because
you know number one you want to make it
accessible to people who know nothing
about programming languages
and number two i'd like to talk about
the podcast are the big
ideas behind what's going on not the
specific implementations thereof
so i'm not sure that i would be able to
pull that off in terms of
uh talking about advances in programming
languages in a way that is user friendly
and also big picture oriented
but you know i'm always happy to take
suggestions for possible guests if you
have any in mind
sam barta asks another question he
i just said that you only had to have
one question but he sneaks in another
one which is who would you rather trade
ben simmons or joel embiid so i don't
have to answer that because it's your
second question so therefore i'm not
going to say
who i'd rather trade although i think
the answer is actually pretty obvious
damien alexiev says does the relativity
of simultaneity and the theory of
relativity allow for a frame of
reference from which the temporal
direction of events in our frame of
reference appears reversed
sure 100 i mean nothing special about
relativity there newtonian
space time has the same thing just use a
time
coordinate which counts down instead of
goes up
we actually do that right when we launch
rocket ships ten nine eight seven six
five four three two one right
that is a reversed time coordinate
so you could easily imagine a time
coordinate with respect to which you
would say
the change of entropy is negative with
respect to that time coordinate
no problem doing that either in
newtonian mechanics or in relativity
ellen g says aren't you afraid to live
on
top of the san andreas fault so no not
really afraid of that um for many
reasons number one i don't
live on top of the san andreas fault you
know it runs nearby but i'm not on top
of it
uh number two you know there's there's
always
worries that you can have anywhere in
the world whether it's
weather or natural disasters or diseases
or whatever
i think that southern california is
actually relatively safe compared to a
lot of places
um number three you know we have been uh
you know places like california that
have been subject to earthquakes for a
long time
other places also like japan or other
places in the pacific rim
um have come up with strategies for
dealing with them you know the the
structural integrity of buildings for
example is really really good here in
southern california
in fact if there were a really really
big earthquake which is absolutely
a worry that uh you should take
seriously um
the thing to worry about is not like
your
house would fall down or your apartment
building would fall down or even that it
would
be set on fire or anything like that the
thing to worry about is
it could shear the electrical and water
supplies to the los angeles basis
uh basin right so that's a big problem
because you know you just have an
earthquake that moves two plates with
respect to each other
los angeles love it though i do is very
much dependent on the outside
world for electricity of course but also
just for water
and so that would be a big problem and
therefore like
any good well-prepared los angelino we
have
um an earthquake kit that has some you
know power
generating uh just solar power
generating things we don't have like a
gasoline power generator but we have
enough food and enough water to get by
for at least a couple weeks
here and so other than that you know you
have to
choose your poisons in terms of bad
things that can happen anywhere and i
think los angeles is not much worse or
better than most places
p walder says following on from the
david eagleman podcast if a congenitally
blind
individual receives visual signals
translated into a set of vibrations in a
vest or some other device
would that person actually have the same
or similar visual experience that a
sighted person experiencing the same
signal directly would have
i'm not exactly the person to ask not
being a neuroscientist myself i think
it's a very good question
my guess is no it would not be the same
experience i'm not even sure though what
it would mean to say
that it's the same experience right this
is the old philosophy
problem of is my experience of the color
red
as a sighted person the same as your
experience of the color red if you were
also a sighted person
and i think that part of the answer to
that question is what do you mean
the same what would that even entail
there could be some operational
similarities in in terms of how you
react and how you respond
to the impulse that you get sensory
input from the outside world
naively of course i would guess that
it's very different because what you're
directly feeling is some touch
or electrochemical stimulation from the
gadget that is very different than what
your eyes do
but in principle i i guess since i'm not
an expert i could imagine
that things get wired up in your nervous
system so that those impulses
go right to what would be the visual
cortex in other people
so i think that the interesting question
here is how
far could you go in arranging it that
these
other sensory modalities actually gave
you exactly or a very very good
approximation
to literal vision um i don't know
i i think it's certainly the current
state of the art not very far but maybe
someday that'll be possible
paul hess says please help me reconcile
the concept that the laws of physics are
completely reversible and not dependent
on the arrow of time
with the concept that quantum
information is destroyed upon
measuring well it depends on your
favorite interpretation of quantum
mechanics right
if you think that
wave functions in quantum mechanics
truly collapse
as some people do whether because you've
measured it or just spontaneously or
because of some
physical trigger there are people who
believe all three of those things those
are three different things one
wave functions collapse because they're
measured two wave functions collapse
randomly three wave functions collapse
when some threshold is reached okay
there are there are
theories of quantum mechanics that rely
on all those different things
but in every one of those options the
laws of physics are not reversible
in the many world interpretation or for
that matter in pilot wave theories
bohmian
hidden variable theories the laws of
physics are reversible
but quantum information is not destroyed
upon measuring
it might be lost it might be lost in
what in in either
either version even though bohmians
don't like to talk about other branches
of the wave function
the wave function still evolves
according to the schrodinger equation
and no information about that is lost it
is still true
that if you knew everything there was to
know about the wave function and you
know the hamiltonian the plug-in to
schroedinger's equation
then you would have the information you
need to evolve the wave function forward
and backward in time
what happens when the wave function
branches is that you have access
to less and less of the wave function
because you only live on one branch
at a time but that doesn't mean the
information is really destroyed it's
just hidden from you
chris rogers says in my fruitless
efforts to understand general relativity
i keep hearing that on earth
objects don't fall due to the pull of
gravity but instead the ground
accelerates up
what's up with that if this is the case
what is driving the acceleration
so yeah i mean this is an optional
but very recommendable shift of
perspective when you go from newtonian
physics to general relativity
in newtonian mechanics the force of
gravity is a force that acts on objects
and accelerates them
much like the electric force or whatever
other other kinds of forces you can
imagine
in general relativity it turns out to be
way more convenient
to define uh at rest or
not i shouldn't say at rest because
that's not well defined but
unaccelerated
right an unaccelerated unforced motion
through the universe
is defined as free fall trajectories
that just
move without feeling anything right when
you're standing
on the ground or sitting on a chair you
feel something the ground is pushing up
against you or the chair is pushing up
against your butt okay
that's not an inertial trajectory what
we would call
a general relativity uh you're being
you're being pushed on
so um the general relativist would say
it's only free fall that we should think
of as an
unforced trajectory and zero
acceleration means you're in free fall
and if that's the case since we're not
in free fall standing on the earth
then clearly the earth must be
accelerating
us and in order for that to happen the
the surface of the earth must itself be
accelerating
so if you want to know what's driving it
it's just the pressure inside the earth
right you're just asking what is holding
up
the earth why is the ground i'm walking
on not freely falling toward the center
of the earth well
the earth is solid and there are
pressure forces inside and those are
pushing
and you feel the push you feel it on
your feet when you walk around
okay it's a it's actually not such a
difficult change of perspective to get
into once you're used to it even though
the language is a little bit different
than maybe what you were
grown up with stefan bernicker says
i asked you about the presidential
elections before the elections and i'm
now asking you again
not only about who won but about the
state of u.s society post-election from
the outside it looks like a weird
theater performed by a split society
where the two sides have a very
different perception of reality do you
believe there's a way for the new
administration to bring the two sides
closer together or will we have to learn
to live with a deeply split society in
the united states
well i do think that there is a split
in the united states you know um if
you're interested i did a podcast
episode with will wilkinson on exactly
this
and the it's not just another one with
ezra klein on exactly this
uh with ezra i was talking about
polarization as a political phenomenon
with will i was talking about the urban
rural divide and how that is the single
biggest driver of the polarization
and so you know it's vastly
oversimplified but
the two countries that you have in the
united states are the ones who live in
cities and suburbs
and the ones who are more rural and in
some again
extremely simplistic diagnosis of why
biden won in 2020 but trump won in 2016
it's because people in the suburbs
switch from being republican voters to
democratic voters a little bit so the
urban
democratic sphere widened a little bit
to include some suburbs
um i don't and you know so the point of
both those podcasts was again in the
very mindscape tradition we weren't just
trying to place blame on this side or
that side we were trying to understand
is there some reason why this
polarization
seems larger now than it used to be
without being a value judgment just
trying to understand it and there are
reasons why i mean in some
you know as ezra points out you know in
some sense
it was surprising 40 50 years ago when
we weren't as polarized as we are right
now that's the surprise in some sense
we're returning to
um a sort of more natural state
now that is enormously complicated
by the change in the media landscape
right by the fact that people get their
news
in very different ways than they used to
so that provides an
engine for increasing the partisan
divide to the point where as you say
it's almost like they have a different
perception of reality so but the other
thing
which i talked about with ezra was that
you know politicians are just becoming
better
game theorists in some sense and they're
realizing that
some of them are realizing that the way
to win the political game
of being elected over and over again if
that's your goal
is not always the way to make the
country better
so if all you ever want to do is get
elected
and that's what politicians want to do
if that's true
then you're in trouble then you can game
the system and
the country will suffer thereby so
that's the question
to ask you know as we've seen the um
attempts
to overturn the election results fail
miserably
on the one hand we can be um happy that
a lot of
local officials even republicans uh
have been very firm in not allowing uh
fair election results to be overturned
but at the same time we can be
disappointed that a lot of
national uh republican officials seem to
be perfectly happy with the attempt
even if the attempt fails right um it
certainly seems as if
you know if the election had been a lot
closer then they would have been
perfectly happy to overturn the results
um and it's just it failed because the
the beat down was pretty bad
and so that's a worry going forward
absolutely and i and i think that um
this is why i've talked about democracy
in the podcast and we'll continue to
talk about it because doing democracy
right isn't easy it's not obvious
and as we're learning we're not very
good at it and
that that is something for which i can
say
you know both sides are to blame i think
that saying both sides are to blame in
general
is a bad strategy because often it's
just one side
but the idea that we should
listen to the other side and and take
their
desires into account and try to reason
with them
is an important one and both democrats
and republicans are bad at it these days
nerves are raw right and uh
people are very upset with other family
members and so forth so
i don't know i'm not super duper
optimistic about uh
bridging divides but i know that we have
to keep trying that's the only way to go
forward if we're going to keep this
democratic experiment
going strong clyde schechter says
let's imagine that closed time-like
curves really exist i get in my rocket
ship and follow a trajectory
arriving back where i started before i
left
wouldn't it also follow that my brain
would be in the earlier state as well
and i would have no memory of the
journey
so no that's it i can actually answer
this one it's a rare time travel
question where the answer is perfectly
unambiguous
no you personally move forward in time
that's the idea of being on a closed
time-like curve
you go back in time as far as the
history of the universe is concerned so
you can go back to you know i don't know
1950
but in your personal timeline you are
only getting older
there's no part of you that reverse ages
or anything like that so it is
absolutely not true
that you your brain or your uh memories
would be back in an earlier state that's
one of the reasons why time travel is
hard to understand and probably not
possible
because it breaks the connection between
time as viewed by the universe as a
whole
and time is viewed by you personally
jamie tan says a photon of light's
proper time is zero
a photon of lights proper time is zero i
should have pronounced it
that means that for a photon time and
consequently distance do not exist
making its speed from its own
perspective infinite
but we measure the speed of light to be
186 000 miles per second which is a
finite value now what makes for the
differential
so i always you know there's a tricky
thing to do when you talk about the
perspective of a photon
photons don't have perspectives not just
because they're single
particles although that's more than
enough reason to say they don't have a
perspective
but also because they don't experience
the passage of time
photons don't experience anything at all
if you don't
experience time then you experience
nothing
when we say that the speed of light is
such and such a thing
clearly that's not from the photons
perspective that's from our perspective
we use miles and seconds or centimeters
and seconds or whatever you want okay
so that velocity is what we would
measure using our measuring apparatus
and this this causes a lot of puzzles
with with photons not experiencing time
because
we experience time and we sort of
imagine taking the limit as things slow
down
more and more and more but that's not
how it is there's literally
zero experience when you're a photon
duncan palmer says as the pandemic has
advanced i've noticed many of us have
adjusted our sartorial preferences
in the privacy of your home working
environment what is your daily outfit of
choice and has it changed much since the
beginning of the year
um it hasn't changed much since the
beginning of the year you know i i
i go back and forth a little bit you
know usually it's pretty casual
um you know sweatpants t-shirts hoodie
that kind of thing
um sweater or whatever um but you know
it's i don't like it i know there's a
lot of
smart people whether they're scientists
or business people or whatever
who you know they're extreme examples of
course but
they literally just wear exactly the
same clothes every day because they say
well that saves me
from wasting some of my precious mental
resources on deciding what to wear
that is not me i actually enjoy
things other than just doing the science
or whatever
and one of the things i enjoy is
aesthetic pleasures
looking good and looking at other things
that look good i like it when people
wear
good clothes interesting clothes whether
it's you know casual or formal
doesn't really matter to me but the idea
of wearing clothes
and having a look i think is a part of
what makes life interesting and fun
and so at the same time i can't quite
bring myself to dress up or even dress
as nicely as i would if i were going
into the office
when i know i'm just going to spend all
my time sitting here
at home so um part of me keeps telling
myself i should dress a little bit
nicely if only for jennifer and the
cat's
benefit or maybe maybe for my benefit
but so i haven't gone quite as
slob oriented as some people but i'm
definitely dressing down more
than i had before humberto nani says how
are things in california
like are students able to learn is the
election topic settled down how are you
able to go out and feel safe with regard
to health and things like that
you know it's look it's mostly normal
here in california like i said at the
beginning of the podcast we've
locked down again in terms of going out
at night um
restaurants for a long time now we're
doing outdoor dining
and i i'm really really incredibly
supportive of local restaurants
and heartbroken that they're going to be
suffering so much so we have been going
you know try once a week or two
out to a local restaurant and uh
ordering in
take out a delivery when we can but um
the going out has now gone away
right there's just no more of that for
the next from between now and i guess
three weeks three or four weeks um
because things have gotten bad here in
la
and that also um you know that that i
don't
i will confess i do not follow very much
the whole school situation
since even at cal tech i don't uh teach
courses i think most of the courses
online are
online now at caltech and other
universities in california
but uh doesn't affect my life very much
since i'm not teaching
and so i don't even know whether
pre-college courses
uh schools are are open or not i don't
think you know
it's been a little disappointing um how
local municipalities around the country
and around the world
have chosen to sometimes do things for
what is more political reasons
than for scientific reasons and and
sometimes that criticism is oriented
toward
um not shutting down people don't shut
down as nearly as much as they should
because it's politically bad but other
places they shut down
too many things or the wrong things
right i mean it's just it just seems
hard to get it right
but anyway yeah i mean the election is
is still bubbling along
on twitter and the news media but life
goes on we all know
that come january 20th biden's gonna get
inaugurated
it'll be difficult for him there'll be a
lot of challenges let's just put it that
way
there's a lot of you know regulations
that are being rapidly undone
in the last couple weeks uh as people
try to cause harm on their way out
but uh mostly things are you know going
going on
life is going on and we're going to try
our best to uh pick up the pieces
next year seamus maxwell says i was had
to learn of the recent death of david
graber
anthropologist and author of debt the
first five thousand years and
[ __ ] jobs was he ever on your radar
as a potential mindscape guest
um you know i knew about david graber
and i was aware of his work and and
i think that you know he's the kind of
person who i would think of as a
potential guest but i never
i wouldn't say that i got very close to
inviting him at any point
um of course you know when so many
people who knew and loved his work
said so many nice things after he died i
did feel regretful that i never had that
chance
so there's some lesson in there for you
know living life to its fullest but you
don't know
who is going to be around you know next
year or five years from now so it's not
a very helpful guide to inviting people
on podcasts
sharon says like many people i'm worried
about global rise in right-wing
nationalism and authoritarianism
climate change global wealth and
resource inequalities etc
i'm on the final leg of a phd in physics
and while i love my research topic it
doesn't have a lot of practical
applications
lately i've been wondering what the
ethics of working in such a
non-practical field are when my skills
can be useful elsewhere
for instance while i can't personally do
much about the global rise in
authoritarianism
i know that i have a skill set to switch
to working on climate modeling and
things like that and help fight the good
fight
have you ever felt anything similar
about working in an abstract field
yourself
you know i'm sympathetic to the um
impulse that uh
you know the work that we do in so much
as it's possible
it's nice that that has a tangible
positive effect on the world
and i'm also perfectly aware that most
of the work i do i do
is pretty darn abstract with no
immediate tangible benefits
um but i do think but there's a couple
things going on one is
i think that uh it's important that we
have
a lot of things going on so even when
there are big disastrous things whether
it's authoritarianism or climate change
and so forth
i am absolutely not of the belief that
everyone should drop everything and work
on those things
because that's kind of self-defeating
right i mean the reason why those things
are bad
is because they get in the way of doing
the good parts of
living life and being a human being so
and part of those good parts are
learning about
the world so i think that you know not
just
being a physicist but being a musician
or an artist or a writer
are things that are important to keep
doing
for some fraction of the human
population even as
uh we face important crises and the
other thing is i think that there is
some positive aspect of the work that i
do whether it's
understanding how the universe works at
a deep level might lead to some future
scientific breakthroughs even though
it's a little
loose of a connection but also i can
have an educational
impact right i mean and that is part of
the reason why i don't just
do scientific research and write papers
but i also write books and do podcasts
and give talks and things like that
that's also a reason why the podcast is
not just about physics
because i think there's more than one
message to get out there
um so i'm if if anyone who is going into
physics or planning to go into physics
decides that you know what i want to do
i want to have a more immediate tangible
right away impact
to make the world a better place then
i'm completely on board with that i
think that's a wonderful
reason to switch fields but i don't
think it's necessary i don't think
you're a bad person
i mean what would i say right but i
don't think you're a bad person if you
continue to think about the wave
function of the universe
even as the globe is getting warmer due
to
human climate change-induced kind of
things
i guess i did i ended that sentence
badly not climate change induced
whether because the climate is changing
due to human activity
paul says are there any proposed
solution to the vacuum catastrophe
that you find compelling i'm paul i'm
honestly not sure what you mean
by the vacuum catastrophe do you mean
the cosmological constant problem
which says that uh we think that the uh
vacuum energy should be much bigger than
it is or do you mean a possible vacuum
decay
um or other things like you need to be
give me more details before i can answer
that one sorry maxime alexandrovic
but but sorry to the to any of the
answers that i can think of
to any of the meanings i can think of to
vacuum catastrophe no i do not
find any of the solutions compelling but
i might not understand what you mean
maxim alexandrovich says there's
currently huge social resistance
in poland including massive public
demonstrations and protests
it is caused by the sentence of highest
court it is a new interpretation of
polish constitution which says that it
is not constitutional to abort a
pregnancy
the court argues that the life should be
protected at all cost even if there are
huge chances
that this life will end very quickly
after birth or a child will be deformed
etc
what is your approach to abortion when a
human starts to be human in his act of
compassion to a border life
when is it an act of compassion to abort
a life if according to a series of tests
that's almost sure that it won't be a
normal healthy life
so there's a couple of different
questions that are sort of um
mixed in together here i mean there's
the question of does the mother
of a child does the woman who is
pregnant have a right to
um have an abortion there's a separate
question of is it
um better for the child to be aborted if
it's not going to have a
normal healthy life you know i i'm for
these kinds of questions i'm the the
default answer is that the mother should
decide in my point of view i'm not the
one carrying around this
baby um i certainly don't think that
it's a moral mistake
to give birth to a child even if you
know that it will be
disabled or unhealthy in some way um i
think you have every right to do that
and then you should
you know you do have a responsibility
once it happens to try to make sure that
that child's
life is as as pleasant as possible
um but you know no but i don't
there's so i mean again this is too much
i'm stumbling because there's too much
to say here
one big question is are you a
deontologist or consequentialist about
morality right
so i think that a lot of the discussion
of abortion
you know has this um well a lot of the
rhetoric from people who are against
abortion has this kind of deontologist
perspective where they think that there
is a sacredness to life
and ending life in any way even a
potential life
uh is a moral mistake and i completely
don't share that
conviction i think that uh there's
nothing sacred
about life i'm also not a
consequentialist i'm i think that i'm
sort of a
half and half when it comes to morality
and i don't think that my moral system
is very well articulated so i couldn't
even give you the explicit
um guidelines but i don't think there is
some
number out there like utility that we
should just add up
so i don't think that giving birth to as
many people as possible is a good thing
either um i know the peter singer and
among other people have made arguments
that
uh it is better not to give birth to
people who will suffer when they
once they're born than to give birth to
them but yeah i just i just don't buy
that i think there is some value
in existing but i don't think that we
should work to maximize that value
so but for the down-to-earth practical
questions
let the mother decide it would be my
rule of thumb
dan o'neill says if you could snap your
fingers and instantly have the same
level of knowledge and expertise in some
field of science outside physics what
would you choose and
why ah yeah i thought about that yeah i
mean it's a good question
um there's just too many it's just very
hard to pick and you know the secret
problem with this question
is there's it's a it's not multiple
choice you didn't give me a list of
options
so you know um is all of biological
science
count or is just you know um
paleontology count right i mean the
answer would be very different possible
you know
if i could choose all biological science
i'd probably choose that
um because biology is you know on the
one hand
we've learned a lot and we know a lot uh
on the other hand there's a lot more to
learn and maybe you know combining that
with some physics knowledge
would lead to great things whereas with
you know psychology or sociology or
political science or economics
we know i think relative to what there
is to be known a lot less
than we do with biology and physics so
it would be fun to know that stuff
but maybe a little bit less um tangible
progress could be made
from for someone like me who likes to
you know write down theories and make
predictions and stuff like that
but i i reserve the right to completely
change my mind about this question if i
think about it more because
it doesn't have an obvious answer to me
good question
nathan egan says as i understand it
black hole evaporation is caused by
matter anti-matter pairs forming near
the black hole with one entry and one
leaving
wouldn't the anti-matter particle reduce
the mass of the black hole and the
matter particle increased the mass
with a 50 50 chance of either particle
entering or leaving the black hole
having a net zero effect on its mass
so no um both matter particles
and antimatter particles have positive
mass
there are no particles that have a
negative mass
but a particle can have a negative
energy
from a certain perspective in general
relativity so the
the short i think what you're getting at
here is the difference between matter
and antimatter and
for these purposes there is zero okay
the only question the reason why black
holes lose mass
is because from this perspective of
particle anti-particle
being created one going in one going out
from the point of view of an
outside observer the particle coming out
has a positive energy
and the particle going in has a negative
energy and you might think well how can
a
particle have a positive mass but a
negative energy um
the mass of a particle e equals m c
squared says the energy what you should
do to think of what you mean by the mass
of a particle
is go to its rest frame okay stand next
to the particle
and ask how much energy it has and
however much energy it has divide that
by c
squared we're going to call that
parameter the mass e divided by c
squared is the rest mass of the particle
okay
but to the point of view of someone very
far outside the black hole
the particle falling in they're not in
the rest frame in fact they
can't be in the rest frame the particles
on the other side of an event horizon
so that's why it's okay in some sense
for that in-falling particle to have
negative mass
it has sorry negative energy not
negative mass that's the whole point
um has nothing to do with matter versus
antimatter it just has to do with this
weird quirk of general relativity
that a particle inside an event horizon
can have a negative amount of energy
from the perspective of a person outside
the black hole
nikos zakaragas says do you believe that
uploading our consciousness thus copying
it
would ever really work meaning that even
if we are able to fully copy
our mind in the cloud doesn't that mean
that there would be just an identical
mind
but with a different first person
experience so never be the initial you
but a copy of you
so i think again there's two issues two
sets of issues
colliding here one is could you upload
forget about copying just for a second
could you upload your brain state into a
computer and
essentially continue on your life your
perceptions and your memories and your
feelings and so forth
in a computer and i think that that's
possible in principle
but i think it's super duper hard way
harder than a lot of people suspect it
is going to be but i do think it's
it's impossible it is possible in
principle there's no
objection to that from the point of view
of the laws of physics or something like
that
the second question is you know if you
if it is copying
rather than destroying your brain and
uploading the information
then is there another copy of you sure
but
yeah you know i think that this is
something is driven home by thinking
about the many worlds interpretation of
quantum mechanics
which is that we should think of you
as existing differently at different
moments of time
in the first place you now is not the
you of 10 minutes ago or the you ten
minutes from now
and they have a relationship to each
other there's a reason why
we can usefully think of you 10 minutes
ago as being the same person in some
sense as you 10 minutes in the future
but they're not the same right you have
10 more
20 more minutes worth of memories so if
you take that seriously
the idea that there's a copy of you
that's living in a computer
and therefore there are now two of you
uh shouldn't be any problem at all like
there's one of you before now there's
two of you what that means is
there are two people who share the same
past
but they're different now so it's
exactly like
the many worlds interpretation in that
sense
paul torek says this is a follow-up to
gregory kusnick's question
from last time about the protein crystal
that computes a universe simulation
the crystal starts at some plane call of
the bottom which represents the initial
conditions of the simulated universe
then each successive layer represents
the next state
gregory didn't say anything about
entropy in this simulation suppose we
can group items in each horizontal plane
into macroscopic objects and suppose
entropy increases for those macroscopic
states as we proceed farther
further from the initial plane suppose
this increasing entropy has a lot to do
with how the people of the simulated
universe can remember earlier states but
not later ons etc
does this satisfy your requirement for a
time-like aspect
so that the people in the simulation
could experience something
so i think well so let me be perfectly
honest
my my commitments to questions like this
are not very strong i i'm
not sure what the right answer is to
questions like this i think
there's a good question you know i've
thought about it a little bit
without you know absolutely landing on
an answer here's my tentative answer
there is a sense in which so i think let
me let me just rephrase the thought
experiment in different words to just
make sure that i'm answering the same
question well you can tell me if i'm
answering the same question you're
asking
um if you believe that there's a
four-dimensional block universe that we
live in right three dimensions of space
one dimension of time
if you believe like i do from an
eternalist perspective that all
instances of instances of time are
equally real
that in some sense the four-dimensional
universe is
like a stack of three-dimensional slices
of time with
things in slightly different places so
could you then
create a stack of things
that exist that extend through space
rather than through time
but have all of the characteristics of
you know evolving one
leading into the other obeying some
patterns that we would recognize as laws
of physics and so forth
even though they're extending just
through space not through time
and then would it also be okay to think
of the little parts of that
stack that you've created as
experiencing things having consciousness
and so forth
so my answer is yes in some sense
it would be okay to think of them in
that way
um but not in a very useful sense not in
our sense because our
experience of the world and
consciousness and time is
entirely intertwined with the fact
that we experience time passing in some
way that we
that when we talk about ourselves we
mean some instantiation of matter in a
certain configuration
at a certain moment of time so our
experience of being conscious and making
choices just
relies on the actual time coordinate
that we have or the actual time
direction or the arrow of time or
however you want to put it
so something that is analogous to that
and similar to that
but which from our perspective only
extends in space and not in time
wouldn't be conscious or experiencing in
our sense there might be another sense
in which it is but it would be so
different from ours that it's not clear
to me
what use it would have okay and you know
you're tempted
to say well okay i have this stack of
things i'm going to like poke at it and
change it but then you're automatically
introducing
some change over time which is cheating
by the rules of the thought experiment
so
i think that's my answer but i don't
think i'd claim that it's a very
sophisticated philosophical view so
uh this is one of the things i'm
definitely willing to be open-minded
about
says do you believe space-time is
continuous or discrete how do you think
that could be tested and maybe
eventually proven
um i don't think er you know so the the
deflationary answer is
it's neither one i think space time's
just an approximation
right i think space time is um
a limit in the classical limit to a
quantum mechanical wave function
so when you say the words is space-time
continuous or discrete
you're secretly already talking
classically
you're acting as if there's some thing
called space-time that
could be either continuous or discrete
right
and i don't believe in that thing i
believe in the wave function of the
universe
and i believe that there are different
ways of describing parts of the wave
function of the universe
that to us are described in the language
of classical physics oh look there's
space-time there's some fields or some
objects things like that
so i think the very question of whether
space-time is continuous or discrete is
ill-posed because space-time is not a
fundamental thing
um you do ask how could it be tested or
experimentally proven
there's a related thing so from my
perspective where you should always
start with wave functions and quantum
states first
rather than asking should space time be
continuous or discrete you should be
asking
is the hilbert space is the space of all
possible quantum wave functions
infinite dimensional which is kind of
like continuous or finite dimensional
which is kind of like discrete
and i'm very hopeful that there could be
experimental testable consequences if
hilbert space is finite dimensional
i think it probably is finite
dimensional um
the obvious experimental consequence is
a violation of lorentz invariants a
violation of einstein's sacred principle
that there aren't rest frames in the
universe
okay um and we're looking for those
violations but we don't yet have
a really reliable theoretical prediction
for what the violations
should be so i'm open-minded about that
too i think this is something where
people should be putting a lot more
brain power
into asking what those violations might
be
sean morris says can you help me
understand how photons are massless yet
they have an energy associated with them
if energy is equivalent to mass how do
massless particles like the photon and
gluon exist
so as i said in a different context a
little while ago
energy is not equivalent to mass mass
you should think of mass as
one kind of energy energy is a broader
concept
okay the equation e equals m c squared
does not say
energy and mass are equivalent it says
that there are certain specific
situations in which the energy of an
object
equals its mass times the speed of light
squared namely
when what you're talking about is an
object okay so it's like not a field
pervading all of space but as an
object with a location and an extent and
it's at rest if that object starts
moving
its energy is bigger than m c squared
because it has some kinetic energy as
well as uh the rest energy
also we can have potential energies the
object sitting on the floor or on a desk
or on a mountain
it has other forms of energy over and
above its rest energy
so the what we mean by
mass is just the energy something has at
rest
divided by c squared okay so the thing
about photons and gluons
massless particles is that they are
literally never at rest
they're always moving at the speed of
light to anyone who is not moving at the
speed of light
that's how fast they're going so this
question
how much energy does the thing have when
it's at rest doesn't apply
to a photon and therefore the best we
can do is just say its
mass is zero danielle cortese says
how do you re reconcile your experience
as a conscious observer with the many
worlds interpretation of quantum
mechanics
in particular how do you explain
experiencing only a single branch
since all branches objectively exist it
seems to me that you can't say
that the original before branching
consciousness continues its experience
because it would mean ascribing a
special status to one of the branches
so yes that's true as i just said and as
i go on a great length about
in my book something deeply hidden um
the way that
conscious observers work in many worlds
is that they start out as one observer
and they become more and more observers
when the wave function branches what was
one observer is now multiple
observers so it is certainly not
true that there is any one particular
path through that branching tree that
you call the real observer
there's nothing more real about one than
any of the other ones
but once the branching has happened each
one of them
is an observer experiencing only a
single branch
this is something that is different
in the many worlds interpretation of
quantum mechanics versus
any other theory of physics ever namely
it's a little bit trickier to identify
what you mean
by an observer living in a
semi-classical world
it has to be different because it's not
surprising that it's different is what i
should say because
every other theory of physics before
quantum mechanics the classical world
was just the world
and now many worlds comes along and says
well there are multiple classical worlds
existing in parallel and that means that
that gives you a whole new thing that
can happen where one observer can
evolve into multiple observers in the
future
so i don't think it's weird but you have
to get used to it if you're going to buy
into many worlds that's how it's going
to have to be
amanilapa says i was listening to a
recent talk of yours where you laid out
a research agenda for mad dog ever
readianism
in response to a question you speculated
that it may turn out that while space is
emergent
time may be fundamental i know this is
probably speculative but if such a
picture were to be true
[Music]
will that also imply the block universe
eternalist view may be replaced by a
more
presented picture or did you have
something else in mind
so this is a good question but i think
in my mind the answer is no
so i know that for many people
the reason why eternalism is a good idea
is because of relativity
because um once einstein comes along as
we've already discussed
uh there's no unique special objective
way to slice
space time into different
three-dimensional spaces
evolving with time and therefore once
you get that how in the world can you be
a presentist
i know people who still are presentists
but if we can't even define the present
in any unique objective way then how are
you supposed to do that okay
however i'm not one of those people you
know i am a eternalist but i would have
been an eternalist even in the newtonian
universe even if you
could uniquely divide space and time
into space and time
uh to me the important thing is that the
laws of
physics don't specify any one moment as
real
the laws of physics relate what is going
on in the universe
at different moments but they don't have
a special
finger that points to one moment says
here's the real moment okay that's just
not how the laws of physics work
that that finger wouldn't be doing
anything so to me
whether time is emergent or fundamental
is completely beside the point about
being president versus eternalist i mean
it's true that if time were not
fundamental the whole debate over being
a presidentist versus an internalist
would would lose some of its force
because you know what exists would be a
different kind of thing than what we're
usually
used to thinking about um but if time is
fundamental that doesn't mean i'm
suddenly a presentist it just means that
the whole four dimensional block has a
you know a way of being described in
terms of a time parameter
and by the way this so footnote here
which is a little bit more technical
just because time is fundamental in my
way of saying it and maybe this is not a
good way of saying it but this is the
way that people talk so it's how i talk
time being fundamental doesn't mean that
a certain time coordinate is preferred
okay that's the lesson of relativity
which i do take
on as important which is that different
time coordinates are equally good
so when you start with the schrodinger
equation for example
there's a time coordinate right there in
it it says i d by dt
the time derivative of the of the wave
function exists there in the schrodinger
equation
and so someone can say well isn't that a
preferred time coordinate but the answer
is no
you can you have a schrodinger equation
in qed quantum electrodynamics or other
theories we know are perfectly
lorenzen variant so it's just that you
can
describe exactly the same situation
as a different wave function evolving
with respect to a different time
coordinate
but it's physically the same
four-dimensional universe so in that
sense time being fundamental doesn't
privilege one moment of time in any way
sam says it's my understanding that one
must always be able to normalize a wave
function of any system
and i know that one way to state this is
mathematically is that if you integrate
the wave function over all possible
values of the variables you should get
exactly one
it seems to me if your system had an
infinite number of particles that your
wavefunction depended on infinite number
of variables
such a normalizing integral would not
converge so my question is when you talk
about the wavefunction of the universe
are you making an assumption about the
number of particles or is there a way to
get around this
uh that's a very good question but no
we're not making an assumption about the
number of
particles and i think again like like
many questions that this time
have uh have had there's two things
going on
okay one thing going on is that when
you do quantum field theory or even when
you do quantum mechanics of an infinite
number
infinite dimensional hilbert space the
math is way harder you know it's weird
to me and i'm writing a quantum textbook
now and i'm going to try to highlight
this weirdness
the first thing we do for most quantum
mechanics examples are something like a
particle in a box
or the simple harmonic oscillator or
something like that and these are
all infinite dimensional hilbert spaces
uh which you can roughly think of is
just corresponding to the fact that
if you have one particle in a continuum
you know in a line or a plane or a
volume
there are literally an infinite number
of points where that particle can live
and every one of those points every one
of those physical locations corresponds
to a different dimension of hilbert
space in the quantum version of the
thing
so right away when we teach people
quantum mechanics mathematically we're
teaching them the hardest examples
right but there's also a good reason why
we're doing that because physically
a particle in a box is for something
familiar and trying to do it quantum
mechanically is a natural place to go
um so anyway when we do something like
quantum field theory etc
it's still true that wave functions need
to be normalizable
but doing it is often something people
skate around because the math is just
really hard
but the short answer to your question is
yes things need to be normalized
normalizable the second aspect here is
does this have something to do with the
number of particles
in the universe so number one um
universal nominated particles it's made
of fields or at least the
configuration space is a field space
not particle space so that's the values
of the fields all throughout space
that matter number two
the way that we usually do it is to say
sure space could be infinitely big um
but we just divide by that we divide by
the volume of space
so when you do your integrals you take a
limit right so when you when you
actually if i don't know same if you've
taken quantum field theory yet
but when you do you will often find
depending on how careful
your instructor is you will often find
that you do what we call
working in a box this is really a very
very common quantum field theory
technique
we start in a box of space and we say
here is a fixed box not a physical box
but a region of space where we're going
to start doing things
like letting fields evolve and whatever
and
quantize them in the whole bit and then
and only
after then do we take the limit as the
box gets infinitely big
and when we do that we take it in such a
way so that all the interesting
quantities we want to calculate remain
finite like the density of something
okay or the energy density at some point
the number density of particles you
might observe
stuff like that so there are ways of
accounting for the fact that the
universe could be infinitely big
while still remaining uh loyal to the
principle that wave functions
should be normalizable by the way
again another technical mathematical
point the thing that you integrate
to get 1 is not the wave function it's
the wave function squared
in fact in particular it's the wave
function complex conjugate times the
wave function so psi star psi
so the adjective we apply to this is
square integrable so wave functions need
to be square integrable
psi star psi integrated over everything
needs to equal one
kirkbriggs says what do you think of
perspectival realism as a topology for
eternalism
um so i didn't i think that i understand
perspectival realism
i think i understand eternalism and i
think i understand topology
but i i was not able to figure out how
these words are fitting together so i'm
not gonna be able to answer your
question
so in particular i have no idea what it
would mean to have a topology
for eternalism do you mean a topology
for space-time
um i mean topology you know tells me
the properties of a mathematical space
that are invariant under smooth
deformations
so i really don't know exactly what
you're asking sorry about that
david lang says does the many worlds
interpretation predict that at least one
version of you will
endure eternally the answer is it
depends
it it's possible that there's a version
of me that he endures eternally
um but it's it's not definite and this
is the one of the
there's a is one of the sad things about
many worlds is that we haven't done
enough research on it and so there's a
lot of things we don't know about it
part of the lack of clarity here is that
we don't know whether or not hilbert's
space is infinite dimensional or finite
dimensional
like i said before if hilbert space is
infinite dimensional then the infinite
number of things can happen
and things can grow increasingly
unlikely or increasingly
thinner in the wave function of the
universe while still not ever fading all
the way to zero
whereas if it's finite dimensional
there's only a finite number of things
that can happen and
enduring eternally is not guaranteed
another thing is that you know many
worlds does not say
that everything happens many worlds says
the schroedinger equation is obeyed
so another formal
technical answer to this question is
well you have to tell me what the
hamiltonian of the universe is and the
schrodinger equation and everything and
then i can ask in the limit
as time goes to plus infinity uh is
there any branch of the wave function
where i exist and you know that's a
technical question that we'd have to
answer and i don't know i don't have the
technical ability to do that since we
don't have the hamiltonian for the
universe
and the final point is
we don't even know if time is
fundamental or not right
so if time is not fundamental if it's
emergent
then there might not be any such thing
as eternally there might not be an
infinite amount of time
left in the history of the universe so
many worlds could still be true in some
generalization where time's not
explicitly evolving
but the number of ticks on the clock
that the universe has to experience
could still be finite
so this is just these are all really
really good questions i'm not trying to
blow them off but we honestly just don't
know the answer
joaquim iverson says i don't understand
what it means when you write in your
book that according to the many worlds
theory one branch can be thicker than
another and it gets especially strange
when it has moral implications why would
it be more important to reduce
suffering for a thicker future branch
than for a thinner future
branch so um
i i don't want to go too far into where
it's important to reduce suffering so if
you if you read the chapter that i have
in something deeply hidden about
morality
everything is phrased and very
conditional terms
if you believe this then you should
believe that like i said i'm not a
utilitarian
i'm not you know i don't think that your
moral choices should be made by adding
up
utility in some way but i did try to
make arguments that if you
are a utilitarian here's how you should
think the point is
in many worlds the world is described by
a wave function the world in the
grandest sense all the worlds
there's a wave function okay and wave
functions assign
amplitudes to what will become different
branches
of the wave function so if you have a
spin
that is in an equal superposition of
spin up and spin down we say that it is
one over the square root of two times
spin up plus one over the square root of
two times spin down
and then the probability that you would
find yourself observing one or the other
is that amplitude squared so 1 over the
square root of 2 squared is 1 over 2 so
it's a half okay
but they don't have to be 1 over square
root of 2
and 1 over square root of two they could
be any two numbers whose squares add up
to one
so you could have a particle that is in
a superposition
of square root of two-thirds spin up and
square root of one-third spin down
and when that happens empirically what
we find
is that two-thirds of the time we see
the particle being spin up when we
measure it and one-third of the time
it's
spin down so um
there's a long argument over how to make
that make sense
with the ev ready and point of view but
it's there it is absolutely there
and what i would say is that the way to
make that make sense in the everyday
point of view so the anti-abradians
would say look
there's no such thing as probability in
the everett version of things there is a
branch where it's spin up and there's a
branch where it's spinned down and
there's a hundred percent chance
that there will be those two branches
there's not a two-thirds chance of one
branch and a one-third branch of another
branch
so what the evoredian has to say is you
don't know what branch you're on when
the wave function branches and so you
need to assign
credences and then you make an argument
that the credence should be proportional
to the wave function
squared and one of the arguments is
if you were on the square root of
two-thirds branch
you could branch again right uh you
could branch again you could measure
another spin that was 50 50
and then you would have three branches
so if you agreed ahead of time
that if you measured the spin up you
would branch the universe again
in a 50 50 measurement and if the spin
were down in the first measurement then
you just left it there okay
so you first branch into a square root
of two thirds spin up and then square to
one third spin down
and then you branch again and now you're
left with three branches
all of them have an amplitude of square
root of one third
and that's the point if you're a good
evaredian the
the point you try to argue for is that
only when branches have
equal amplitudes should they be treated
equally
and there's a lot i'm not going to go in
right now into why you do that there's
lots of arguments and you
debate which is the best argument
decision theory or some epistemic
rationality or some principle of
indifference or other different kinds of
things
but the point is that that's what gets
you the right answer okay
you treat branches of the wave function
equally
when they have equal amplitudes and it
immediately follows that you don't
treat branches of the wave function
equally when they don't have equal
amplitudes
because if you did then you could split
one of them again and you
now there's two of them and you can't
you're changing x post facto
the way that you treat those worlds okay
and
by the way this goes along perfectly
with how we think about things like
energy conservation where does the
energy come from when you branch into
multiple worlds
well the amplitudes that the square root
of 1 third square root of two-thirds
outside the branches
those get squared and multiply the
energy
so if your two branches have equal
energies
then you don't create twice as much
energy
by branching the universe you create
square root of two thirds
squared times the energy plus square
root of one third square
times the energy and that's the same
amount of energy that you had before
so whether it's probability or energy
or utility a self-consistent happy
everettian
will weight what goes on in branches of
the universe
as the wave function squared it's the
only way to be a good ever readyan
okay and you can justify that again
there's many ways to justify
it you can say well imagine that i did a
maximal amount of branching
and then i just count right the number
of branches you could fit
into the wave function the universe is
proportional to the amplitude squared
that's one thing that's just
pythagoras's theorem that's why if you
go back to
something deeply hidden i say that it's
ultimately just comes down to pythagoras
theorem
but anyway the very short answer to your
question is everything
to an average and has to be proportional
to the amplitude squared
ken wolfe says do you think there is a
way that a dyson sphere could be
surrounded by some sort of parabolic
mirror
that directs all the waste heat in one
direction such as into a black hole as a
stealth measure
um i like how you're thinking how to
hide the dyson spheres
um you know uh with 30 seconds of
thought having gone into it
yeah that seems plausible to me i mean
there will always be some waste heat
because your mirrors will also give off
heat but i think that
and i'm not i'm not saying that your
scheme with the mirrors is necessarily
the most efficient way of doing that
um but the general idea that in
principle
you could take the so the idea for the
any of the
you who have been living lives somehow
did not
come into contact with this this thought
if you build a dyson sphere that is to
say if you surround
um a star in all
four pie stradians uh you know in all
directions you build a sphere that
completely encompasses a star
so you're trapping a lot of energy right
stars giving off energy
and it will heat you up and so on the
other side of the sphere
outside of the star you will necessarily
radiate into space
and so this is thought to be a way to
look for dyson spheres out there in the
sky
by looking for these large but
duly radiating objects that are
otherwise star-like
so you know you could just i mean make
your life easier
surrounded by i don't know if it's
easier or harder but surrounded by a
whole bunch of more spheres
right and continually degrade the
radiation to lower and lower
frequencies higher and higher larger
larger wavelengths so
you need to emit the same amount of
energy but if you
shift it all to longer and longer
wavelengths and maybe it's harder to
detect i don't know maybe it's easier or
maybe
it would be easy if you knew where to
look but you don't know where to look so
but i think in principle there are
things you can do
to try to hide your dyson spheres from
nosey astronomers yes
jose ignacio alcantara says i wonder how
you feel about graduate students taking
on a teaching load do you think this
could be beneficial for them
or might you be concerned that in their
eagerness to please senior faculty
members they might be taken advantage of
well there's always a possibility of
graduate students and their eagerness to
please senior faculty members being
taken advantage of
that's something that graduate students
should look out for
and departments should look out for in a
more systematic way
i actually think that it is useful for
graduate students to do some
teaching after all many of them
certainly many of them in physics are
going to want to eventually become
professors where teaching will be part
of their job
i think we do a terrible job overall in
teaching
students how to be good teachers which
would be an important thing
down the road on the other hand you know
you can get a lot more work done a lot
more research i should say
done if you're not teaching so there's
definitely a place for
fellowships that uh release graduate
students from teaching at some point so
there's a balance there
you know i was on fellowships when i was
a grad student but i taught a couple
times
uh voluntarily because it's good
experience and i enjoy doing it
frank layman says to what extent do most
working theoretical physicists keep up
with new developments in higher
mathematics
has any of your own work relied on truly
cutting edge maths
research um i think it depends very much
on exactly what kind of theoretical
physicist you are
i think people will be surprised at how
many
theoretical physicists do not keep track
of new developments or even old
developments in higher mathematics
you know a lot of theoretical physics
let's say you're a particle physicist
who wants to you know suggest some new
set of fields that are interacting with
each other and calculate their decay
rates and stuff like that
there's a certain set of tools you need
which is a lot of math a lot of complex
analysis
and integration and group theory and
things like that
but it's the same stuff year to year you
don't really require more math
as time goes on there is a small part of
theoretical physicists who are very very
mathy right typically people we think of
as string theorists
uh the edwins of the world who is
basically creating new math
as he goes along and that's but that's a
small
proportion of them and i think that
there's also
a whole bunch of people which i would
include myself where
it's not that we're learning new math or
keeping track of new math
for its own sake but sometimes we're
trying to learn new things
and to learn new things new areas of
physics
that often requires learning new
mathematics right when you when i want
to learn
information theory or something like
that i will have to learn new math along
with the physics
that's i think something that you're
trained to do but you're doing it
for a purpose to learn this new bit of
physics not because it's cool new math
who knows maybe it'll be interesting
someday
richard kashtan says can you explain the
acceleration
aspect of twit the twin paradox i heard
it once but don't remember it and don't
really understand it and
uh i edited down that question a little
bit i think that one point about the
thing i edited richard is that
you use the phrase aging slower and
i would never use that phrase i don't
know what it means to age slower you age
at one year per year that's the work
that's the uh
amount by which you age i think if
people want to understand
the twin paradox it's very very helpful
to do it right to think about it
correctly
individual people no matter what
trajectory they're moving on in the
universe
age at one year per year the amount of
elapsed
time on two different trajectories
might be different right but it is
really exactly like
moving through space and i've used this
analogy before and i will continue to
use it
when you're walking from point a to
point b
you could go in a straight line or you
could go on a curved path
you're always traveling at one meter per
meter right you're not moving
at a different rate of space per space
but you will take a different amount of
distance
depending on whether or not you go in a
straight line or a curved line
it's exactly the same thing for
traveling through time except with the
one difference
that the shortest path in space
is a straight line and the longest time
in time is a straight line
so the fact that you age
less when you zoom out on a rocket ship
turn around and come back than if you do
if you just sat here and didn't move
is not because of the acceleration it's
because you're not taking a
straight-line path
now admittedly the only reason you can
not take a straight-line path is because
you did acceleration right so there's a
relationship there
um but tim maudlin in one of his books
on the foundations of physics when he's
talking about space-time you know he
points this out
if you take two twins and they start at
the same point
and one immediately accelerates off in a
rocket ship zooms out a long distance
immediately accelerates back whereas the
first one just stays put so in space
time they're forming basically a
triangle
right then there can be a big difference
in
the amount of time elapsed between the
two trajectories
whereas if the second twin if sorry if
the twin that leaves
the twin that zooms out zooms out very
quickly but then
immediately turns around and comes back
they can do
the same acceleration right
they're doing it at different times
they're doing the the return
acceleration
sooner but if you think about you know
just accelerating off
freely floating accelerating to turn
around and come back
if you do that quicker and then you get
back to where you started quicker and
you decelerate to stop
then the difference in time elapsed is
much shorter
than if you are traveling near the speed
of light for almost that whole time and
do your acceleration only at the halfway
point
the point of this example is the
difference in time does not
in any sense come from the acceleration
the difference in time elapsed comes
from the fact that you're taking a
different path
through space-time a path that is very
close to being a straight
line or a path that is very far away
from being a straight line that is what
matters
peter benham says is there such a thing
as zero velocity in the absolute
anywhere in the universe or is it all
just relative
how can we determine who is taking the
slowest path through time if there is
such a thing
so again there's no such thing as the
slowest path through time everyone is a
one year per year one second per second
the total amount elapsed can be
different for different people
but it doesn't depend on zero velocity
because velocity is not well defined
velocity according to relativity is
something that is only relative to an
observer
but there's a huge difference between
velocity and acceleration
there's no such thing in relativity as a
absolute velocity but there is such a
thing as an absolute acceleration
and you know that because if you imagine
yourself out there in a rocket ship
you have no idea if you don't look
outside the rocket ship how fast you're
moving
but you absolutely know how fast you're
accelerating because you can feel the
push
on your feet if the rocket is
accelerating okay that's what determines
whether or not you were on
what we call a geodesic a straight-line
trajectory through space-time
or whether you are not on a geodesic and
it's those geodesics those straight line
paths
that will that will experience the
longest time
between any two events nathan simmons
says
thanks to your book the big picture
whenever i put creamer into my coffee i
think about complexity swirls and
entropy
what is another fun similar metaphor for
a physics concept that involves
something we do
every day um that's one of my favorite
ones so i'm not sure but the only one
that comes to mind right now is the one
i just used
the uh analogy between traveling on
different paths whether you're walking
or in a car or whatever versus doing the
twin paradox experiment you know the
twin paradox is about the different
amounts of time elapsed
moving on different paths in space is
about the different amounts of
spatial distance you traverse but it's a
very good analogy and i think the one
that
people find very helpful hugh's math
says i wish
sorry i would think if you took the
derivative of volume of a sphere you
should get the surface area
does not work like that of a circle and
the circumference um
i'm not going to sit down and look at
the formulas but you know when you take
the derivative
of anything you got to say like with
respect to what and you ask
y the derivative of something should
equal something else so you have to
think through these things uh before you
plug in the numbers or see the formulas
don't work
correctly there's different things that
you can differentiate with respect to
other things
matthew caffrey says i'm a science
fiction writer who uses multiple worlds
as a plot device and i want to write a
fictional syn
run a fictional scenario by you if there
was a room
box or planet sufficiently separated
from the rest of the universe
so that there was no significant
physical interaction with the quiet spot
in the outside world
could the wave function of that quiet
spot be considered separate from the
universal wave function
well yes and no certainly it is is
absolutely possible
to imagine subsystems of the universe
that are
unentangled with the rest of the world i
think that's what you mean by separate
you might mean by separate just
non-interacting but in this quantum
context what matters is
are two things entangled with each other
and we
find unentangled things all the time you
know
again to go back to a previous
discussion we had there's a difference
between living on a branch
and considering the whole wave function
of the universe
two things can be unentangled on a
single branch but entangled on the whole
wave function as a whole or vice versa
so it's a little bit complicated when
you say are two things entangled with
each other or not
but having said that typically when we
measure something so you measure the
spin of a particle and it's spin up
now you're entangled with that particle
but on your branch
it just is spin up it's not still
entangled with you in the wave function
of the universe it's entangled
but on that branch it is not so having
said that
the question is can you in the wave
function of the universe
have a subsystem of the universe that is
so isolated so that it's unentangled
with everything else
um yes you absolutely can imagine that
in principle
in practice it'll be really hard to pull
off
i mean you talk about sort of isolating
a box under the earth or in a quiet room
or whatever
but you know photons count photons are
emitted
by any object at a non-zero temperature
and photons do
interact with other things so even if
you built a room and a box
and put it out in outer space uh in the
desolate cold of intergalactic space
it is still constantly being bombarded
by photons from the universe you know
that because you look outside you see
the galaxies
if you had a radio telescope you could
see the microwave background et cetera
so it still wouldn't be a hundred
percent
isolated in that true sense fedor
indonti says uh in
says most physicists agree that gravity
is quantum in its nature
given that the mean main field in
relativity is the metric tensor itself
would you agree that quantizing gravity
implies the existence of a minimal
distance such as the plonk length if so
does it mean its space time has to be
discrete
so no i don't agree with that at all i
mean maybe it's true but there's no
logical derivation of a statement like
that and keep in mind
quantum has nothing to do with discrete
these two words are completely separate
i know that before quantum mechanics
came along
the idea of a quantum was in fact a
discrete discrete lump of something
but quantum mechanics by itself does not
imply
discreteness again this is something i
talked about at great length
in something deeply hidden what quantum
mechanics implies about space-time
is that there is a wave function and the
wave function assigns different
amplitudes to different ways that
space-time could be
that's it that's what it implies just
like if you quantize an electron
it doesn't imply that the electron only
has certain locations
it can take if that electron is stuck
inside a potential like the electrical
potential caused by an atom
then maybe there are discrete energy
levels it could be in but the number of
places that the electron could be seen
if you look for its position
is still infinitely big so there's no
direct route
to go from quantizing gravity to minimal
distance in any sense
philip meyman says is it fair to say
that measurement resulting from true
quantum randomness like spins and
locations of particles
are new information in our observed
branch of the universe
in a way that non-quantum random
measurements like the outcome of a coin
toss are not
if so then does that become new
information at the earlier moment of
decoherence with the environment or at
the later moment when an observer
at the edge of the environment finally
becomes entangled with it
so i think that the short answer to your
question is the observer is completely
irrelevant here
who cares about observers there are
physical processes going on in the
universe and the coherence is one of
them and that's what matters
now when decoherence happens you go from
a situation where let's say to make our
lives easy
you had one branch of the wave function
before and then you have two
after so the transition from
the one to the two is completely
smooth and uniform and according to the
schrodinger equation
but the the evolution from the one wave
function to
either one of the two which is what an
observer would measure
uh is not smooth and continuous that's
why we fool ourselves into thinking that
wave functions collapse okay
so the wave function changes in some
discontinuous way
from the point of view of an observer
but again the word observer doesn't mean
like a human being it just means any big
macroscopic
classical thing does that count as new
information or
old information you know and the answer
i would say is you know
do who cares so it does just it just is
up to you whether you want to call that
it's different information
so it's new in that sense but all the
information that was there was
somehow encoded in the wave function of
the universe
as a whole before that event actually
happened
johnny says after your podcast about
democracy you got me thinking if we had
someone truly admirable and virtuous to
take charge would you
ever consider a benevolent dictatorship
scenario this is just a thought
experiment out of curiosity
um so i can certainly admit that if we
were um infinitely smart
and able to if we were omniscient and we
knew that a certain person
was infinitely good and wise then that
person would be
better in charge of the country or the
world than any
democratically elected legislator would
be but we're not like that it's like
imagining that we're being
laplace's demon in the real world
you can trick yourself into thinking
that someone is perfectly good or even
pretty darn good and wise
um and be terribly terribly wrong and
besides which
i think in you know in the real world
it's just crucially important
that the authority of the government
comes from the people right and a lot of
people will say you know
well people aren't very good decision
makers people like the hoi polloi you
know they're not very smart they're not
very informed not very educated they're
not very rational
why should we give them the right to
decide what's going on
and the point of democracy never was
that it was the best
decision-making process it's not as if
you let
millions of people vote and you're most
likely to get the right
answer in some sense the point is that
people care about their own interests
people are going to stand up for
themselves and
in ways that uh people in positions of
power
who are just given that power over other
people are not gonna
do so so i don't think that
realistically there is ever any
benevolent dictatorship scenario
that i'd be in favor of both because i
don't think we could do a good job
picking the benevolent dictator
and because i think that it's not the
right in principle way
to govern a country nathan morgan says
if a black hole is fully described by
its angular momentum charge and size
to me that suggests very low entropy we
know everything there's no uncertainty
if it's possible high entropy is related
to go
what's going on inside so are black
holes high or low entropy
so yeah i mean this is exactly the
reason why hawking and beckenstein's
discovery of black hole entropy
was surprising in classical general
relativity
which is where it is true that a black
hole is fully described by its angle
momentum charge and size
then there's not a lot of microstates as
we would say
right so if you go back to when
boltzmann invented the modern concept of
entropy
it was based on the fact that if you
have a box of gas or a cup of coffee or
whatever
you can think of that as a collection of
many many atoms or molecules arranged in
different configurations
in classical general relativity there's
nothing inside a black hole that is
being arranged in many many different
ways and therefore you would not expect
it to have any entropy
at all so when hawking bekenstein
derived the fact that it had entropy it
seems to be implied by that but we have
to be a little bit careful because we
don't know
you know this is an area of physics that
is not completely understood
but it seems to be implied by that that
there are
many many different little micro states
that the black hole could be
in and that what we're observing is the
big macroscopic black hole is some
superposition or combination
of all these microstates um so what are
they well that's the good question
that's what we would like to know we
would like to know what they are and how
they work
to make black holes make a bit more
sense
justin bailey says what if the speed of
light was 10 times faster would the
universe behave any differently
so i'm going to be a curmudgeon here
when you say 10
times faster i would have to ask
compared to what
you know uh the speed of light is one
light year per year
it can never be any faster than that it
can't be any other number
what you really mean is if you think of
the speed of light as
300 000 kilometers per second uh
would you really mean is what if seconds
were longer
or what if kilometers were shorter and
when you say it that way
it's clear how very human-centered that
kind of thing is
now you could imagine and people have
imagined
for whatever reason you could imagine
changing all of the laws of physics
so that you change the size of atoms
and the speed of atomic transitions and
chemical reactions and the size of
elementary particles and the masses of
elementary particles and the interaction
strength of elementary particles you
change
everything exactly in the right way in
concert
so that uh what you would call
a meter does really change so that in
fact the
speed of light is 3 million kilometers
per second rather than 300 000
kilometers per second
um so that's how that's the answer would
it be different
yeah i mean you're changing all the laws
of physics
uh in some way to make that happen and
what you know what the
results would be you know how life would
be different i'm really not sure
that's not something i really thought
about pete harlan says
you and your loved ones and a few
friends have an opportunity to travel to
earth a thousand years in the future
if there are people there you are among
them they're friendly they're expecting
you
and they will know where and when you
came from you can't return
and nobody else can make the journey
forward would you do it what if it were
10
000 years 100 or a million years
i actually don't know i think my first
impulse is that i would
not do it and the you know the point is
that
i am i live here i'm embedded in the
world as it is right now
i have you know a lot of friends right
and i can bring a few friends i'd be
leaving other people behind but i also
i understand the current world to some
extent
i'm doing work pushing back the
frontiers of knowledge and things like
that
uh i know where to go to have a good
time all those things i understand this
world i understand that this world as it
is
right now is extremely flawed in many
many ways
um but i know how to deal with that and
and try to make it better whereas
the world a thousand years from the
future um i guess i'm allowed by this
thought experiment to bring
a few friends along but there's still a
whole bunch of people i'm leaving behind
i don't know the world and i could learn
it but
uh i would always feel like a stranger
in a strange land in some sense
i mean having said that i do get the
attraction of the thought experiment
because i'm
hopeful that the world will be a much
better place a thousand years from now
you know if you do the same thought
experiment thinking of someone a
thousand years ago
would they like to be moved up to here
certainly
you know sanitation and healthcare and
education are much better now than they
were
back then um but the other consideration
is
you know there's no guarantee that the
world a thousand years from now
is anything like our current world right
you know a thousand years ago things
were very very different but they're
still
kind of like the world we have now right
there are still people
and horses and stuff like that um
whereas
technology is changing so rapidly that
in a thousand years things could be
dramatically different you know maybe we
live all in a simulation or
maybe we've destroyed ourselves we're
all living on different planets or
you know we're all um change our uh
genomes so that we live forever
uh who knows like the world could be
much different
between now and a thousand years in the
future than it is from now to a thousand
years ago
so it's not at all clear that a thousand
years from now would be hospitable to
people like me even if there are people
there and they're friendly
uh maybe the world would have changed so
much that i wouldn't enjoy it anymore i
just don't know
so um my guess is i would try to make
the most of the world we have right now
brad malt says in your view possible
outcomes exist in superposition until
they become entangled with their
environment
whereupon the wave function decoheres
and the outcomes are represented by
separate worlds
but we can never communicate with or
observe any of these many worlds except
our own
instead of all these many worlds an
alternative explanation might be that
the wave function represents
probabilities and when it collapses the
outcome is the world we experience
why isn't this one world explanation a
simpler more intuitive better
explanation or at least alternative
possible explanation so
you can try to develop theories like
that and people have but the short
answer as to why it doesn't work
is because wave functions seem to be
physical things
they don't just represent probabilities
and we know that because wave functions
interfere with each other right that's
what the double slit
experiment tells us you put the wave
function of a single particle through
two slits and the wave function seems to
be like a wave it goes up and it goes
down and it constructively or
destructively interferes on the other
side
if there was such a thing as just the
probability that the particle goes
through one slit or the other
and lands somewhere on the other screen
then you would just add up the
probabilities there'd be no interference
pattern between that it's experiments
like that that make us think
that wave functions are real physical
things not just ways of talking about
probabilities
gregory kusnick says suppose your future
self steps out of a wormhole shows
convincing proof of his identity and
tells you to rob a bank
you have no reason to want to rob a bank
and every reason not to
since you'll most likely get caught go
to prison and ruin your life indeed
your future self tells you that's
exactly what happened to him to his
everlasting
regret he can't believe he let himself
be talking to such a harebrained
venture nevertheless he fully expects to
talk you into it and the single
consistent world model of time travel
says
he must succeed even though he has no
real argument to offer beyond the fact
that he was talked into it
is that fact sufficient to convince you
and whose idea was it to rob a bank in
the first place
so this is a very good question because
it it sort of
highlights the conflict
between time travel and single
consistent world versions of time travel
and our everyday intuitive experience of
free will right
in this thought experiment why can't i
just choose to not rob the bank
and indeed i think in this thought
experiment i would
choose not to rob the bank because i
don't want to rob the bank so
what would happen well either
for some unknown reason that is very
unclear to me
the universe would conspire to force me
to rob the bank
or i would learn that the guy was lying
to me my future self was not telling me
the truth he was trying to
test me to see whether or not i'd be
smart enough to realize that he might
not be telling the truth
um and so i'd rather i would try to do
that so
i don't think that you know the the
one thing about time travel is even if
you believe
i guess the third possibility is maybe
the metaphysics is wrong and it's not a
single consistent world and i could
change things who knows
but even if i thought that there was
just a single consistent world
if there was time travel in that world
there's no
obligation on my part to try to make it
a single consistent world
it just will be a single consistent
world no matter what i try to do like
there's lots of dumb ways to do time
travel
but the dumbest way is to imagine that
we have to not disturb
the timeline okay you know the timeline
is going to be the timeline
you're not going to disturb it so if
it's
your scenario is exactly like a
prophecy right a prophecy that says on
this date i will rob the bank and it's
by someone who is
foretold the future many times and has
100 accuracy right
that's just not the way the real world
works and so we're not used to it
what the question is what would we do if
we were faced with that and i i still
think i would try not to rob the bank
and
see what happened antonio justino says
you've obviously thought a lot about
entropy in the second law of
thermodynamics to me it's always seemed
incomplete
like we're missing a corollary usually
the patterns we see when we study the
world are described with
equalities but here it tends to
inequality
that being i think that the point being
that uh entropy
increases but the amount by which it
increases is not specified by the second
law
could it be that we're not capturing the
true measure of the low entropy of
states such as my memory my computer's
hard drive or the unique
uniqueness of the arrangement of atoms
in my ama question to you
could the increasing entropy of the
universe on one hand be balanced with
the increasing order that we see
in parts of it so i think i mean i know
what you mean the second law is a much
more loosey-goosey law than other things
that we think of as laws of physics
right
it is like you say an inequality not an
equality
um so yes there is
a an equality behind it all but that
equality is just
the exact underlying microscopic laws of
physics
so the point is not that we increase the
entropy here
and balance it with increasing order
somewhere else that's not
part of anyone's law of physics the
point is if you describe the universe
microscopically so you describe the
exact quantum state of the universe or
the exact classical state or whatever
laws of physics you're going to believe
in for the moment then the word entropy
doesn't apply
because the whole idea of the word
entropy is that we've forgotten
something we've coarse grained or we
have incomplete access
to the information about the microscopic
state of the universe that's the only
situation in which
entropy becomes a useful concept so
it's not true that the second law is
just incomplete in and of itself
it's trying to describe a situation of
incomplete information
and therefore it tells us something
incomplete about the future
chris shaw says my question is
everything in space time is a product of
some form of energy through e
equals m c squared all mass matter
radiation anti-matter dark matter even
dark energy that's literally everything
in the cosmos
all that's left is space is it possible
that space is a product of energy as
well
or the side effect of reactions between
different kinds of energy
um i don't think so so
um i think that this is not how a modern
physicist thinks about it i'm hesitating
because you know maybe there's some
other way of thinking about it
but the the very um hypothesis of the
question
everything in space time is a product of
some form of energy through e equals m c
squared
is not exactly right as we said just
before
e equals m c squared is an equation that
applies to a
very very restricted set of things
it applies to things that are objects so
they have both locations and extent in
space
and they are objects that are at rest
okay so it doesn't apply to things like
fields or dark energy there's
equals mc squared is just meaningless in
the concept of
in the in the uh context of dark energy
it doesn't apply to radiation because
radiation is moving at the speed of
light it cannot possibly be
at rest okay so you know energy is
important
but it's not everything there are other
things there are other important ideas
that you need in fact i would honestly
go to say the energy is one of the less
important things energy is a derived
quantity if you tell me what everything
else in the universe is doing
i can tell you it's energy but if you
tell me it's energy i can't specify what
all the things
are right kc says
might entanglement decay that's a
curious question if time itself might
emerge from
entanglement so you know entanglement
can decay if you do things to a system
but there's no rule that says
entanglement has to decay
if you have two particles that are
entangled let's say maximally entangled
and you just let them sit there you keep
them isolated from the rest of the world
the entanglement between them does not
change over time it does not either
increase or decrease in in general
um again you can perturb it you can
change it with an influence from the
outside world but there's no reason for
entanglement to decay all by itself it's
not like
it's not like you know two people
holding hands where they get tired okay
it's really just not like that it's a
different kind of thing
trevor villewalk says what do you
suspect the implications of
eternalism are for consciousness what
does it mean for our conscious self
to in some sense exist eternally at
every moment in our timeline
and how do you reconcile this with the
phenomenon of consciousness being tied
so closely to individual present moments
flowing forward in time
well i don't you know i i have trouble
understanding what
presentists really think so i'm not
always very good at
uh explaining what eternalists think
cause it's always in contrast with a few
i don't understand so
eternalists think that what exists is
the four-dimensional world
all the moments in time have some equal
amount of existence
but when you talk about what a person is
believing or thinking or experience at
any one moment of time
then you're taking a slice through that
four-dimensional world and picking out
what is going on
at that moment and you know as i
discussed
various times various places for example
in the podcast with janean ismail
we talked about the psychological
aspects of the arrow of time a little
bit
and the point is that that person at any
one moment of time
has a memory of the recent past
and also is trying to predict the
immediate future right
and so even though they exist in
principle at one moment of time
they are constantly making reference to
changing moments of time to moments in
the immediate past in the immediate
future
and their environment around them is
changing as well as their internal
changes
so it's really a give and take kind of
thing
you are sort of interacting with and
being influenced with the world around
you
while entropy is increasing all along so
of course consciousness is something we
don't completely understand
but the fact that consciousness seems to
experience this flow of time
is related in exactly that way to the
fact that entropy is increasing now
having said that there's an enormous
amount of work remaining to be done
to spell this out and if you thought
that the words i just said
sounded kind of vague and incomplete
that's because they are so there's
plenty of
research yet to be done in thinking to
make this connection between the arrow
of time and consciousness
perfectly clear brian tidmor says does
information have mass does information
create mass
or does information rearrange existing
energy mass
so i would go back to what i just said
about energy kind of being less
important
than other things i think information is
exactly the same way i think of both
energy and information as ways of
characterizing the stuff
of which the universe is made okay and
you can debate depending on your
particular fundamental ontology what is
the stuff of which the universe is made
but energy and information are on very
very much
the same um level in terms of
what their role is in the physical
playing out of the world
that is to say in some sense you don't
need them
if you just told me what the quantum
state of the world was in the
hamiltonian the plug-in schrodinger
equation
that's all i need or if you're a
newtonian kind of person
all you tell me is the position and
velocity or the point in phase space of
every little bit of the universe
that's all you need then you can run
that forward and backward and words like
information and energy and entropy for
that matter
would never enter your vocabulary but as
human beings
we find it enormously helpful to
attach words like energy and information
to different physical configurations
it's an example where that kind of
conceptual handle on what's going on
gives us enormous insight so that's my
way of thinking it i think that
information is secondary it's parasitic
on
the stuff but having said that you know
i say that very hesitatingly because
it can be really really useful to think
that way even if it's parasitic on stuff
it's a very useful
concept you know i wrote a paper with
some several collaborators on the
bayesian second law of thermodynamics
which is part of this
research program that is going on in
various circles to
understand the relationship between
information and entropy and
thermodynamics and work and energy and
things like that
and by knowing something about a system
you can manipulate in it in such a way
to extract energy from it okay see
there's an interplay between energy and
information
my point is just that i don't need to
know any of those words if all i
knew was that there was stuff acting in
a certain way that's a complete
description in some sense
fran ploss says which were the coolest
christmas gifts that you ever got
either as a child or a teen ah so this
is a tough one
to be perfectly honest i don't i don't
uh
rank my christmas gifts or even have
very vivid memories of them
um you know i remember getting gifts and
i couldn't even tell you which of them
were for christmas versus other times
like
i used to like playing with model
rockets when i was a kid and things like
that
the one christmas gift that i actually
remember very very vividly and this is
going to really
be like the nerdiest thing i've ever
said on this podcast which is saying
something
the christmas gift i really remember
getting was a desk
and i loved having it i wanted a desk
you know i wanted some place to sit and
read and write and things like that
that's what i really wanted more than
anything else and i got it and
but i think i suspect that as important
and as
good as it was for me to get the desk
one of the reasons why i remember it so
vividly is it was really hard to hide
that desk under the christmas tree
so it was you know under a big blanket
or whatever and i knew perfectly well
what i was going to get ahead of time so
that played a big role in me remembering
it to this day
paul hardy says wondering about the
model that says the universe might
expand then contract
expand etc in the big crunch i know all
the matter would collapse in on itself
but what would cause
space itself to collapse why wouldn't
only the matter collapse due to gravity
well the basic answer is that uh space
goes along with matter according to the
rules of general relativity you know
there's a more subtle answer which is
that when you say
space is collapsing what is that
supposed to mean right especially
because
there's no rule that says space can't be
infinite
and yet still collapse okay when we say
space is collapsing we're
kind of using a metaphorical language um
because i mean here's how the actual
cosmologists are thinking about this
um i have a universe it has a metric
a way of describing the geometry of
space and it also has stuff inside okay
particles galaxies or whatever
so think about in particular a cosmology
so not just a random collection of
particles but particles that are
uniformly distributed through space
either expanding or contracting then the
easiest way to describe
that is by choosing coordinates
on space such that the particles
basically don't move
with respect to those coordinates okay
so the coordinates have a distance
between them that changes over time
because the particles are coming closer
and closer if the universe is collapsing
and therefore we attach words to that
namely that
space is collapsing but we don't have to
do any of that we could choose
completely different coordinates we
could choose coordinates in which space
wasn't changing at
all but all the particles are moving
within space
rather than having their spatial
coordinates tied to where the particles
are
that would be clumsy it would be hard to
do it the equations would not look very
pretty
but you could do it if you wanted to the
physical reality is that the density of
matter is increasing
and there's another physical reality in
that the curvature
of space is increasing when you collapse
to a big
big crunch or when you come out of the
big bang and going to the past
um so that's basically i hope that's a
useful
answer like part of it is there's a
physical thing happening
namely the curvature of space time
changing but also part of it is there's
just a way of speaking that we have that
is convenient
anders says you've said that the reason
particles decay is an increase of
entropy a neutral meson decays into two
photons and there are more ways to
arrange two photons than one meson
but wouldn't entropy increase even more
if the meson decayed into four photons
shooting off at right angles
and repeat that reasoning until we have
mesons decaying into an infinite number
of photons shooting off in all
directions why doesn't that happen
so the very short answer here is that
there is no law of nature
that says that entropy has to increase
as much as it can
right so the process
i mean i'm not sure exactly what my
words were but it's not quite right
to say that the reason particles decay
is increase of entropy
increase of entropy is the reason why it
is more often for a particle to decay
than to a bunch of particles to come
together and form one particle
okay that irreversibility that that
difference in
rate it's not a strict irreversibility
because sometimes particles can come
together and form just one
but it is much more common for single
particles to decay
that's because that increases the
entropy of the universe
that's what makes it more likely but not
what makes it possible
okay but anyway there is no rule that
says that entropy increases as fast as
possible or as much as possible so
the processes that do happen will
increase the entropy of the universe
but to figure out which processes happen
it's not enough to just say well what
would increase the entropy you have to
figure out what the actual laws of
physics say happens
paul cousin says do you know when the
quantum physics textbook you're working
on is going to be ready approximately
well it's not gonna be for a while let's
put it that way it's not even due for
more than a year from now okay
so i think it's due in early 2022
so if it's published by later in 2022
i'd be happy
but i can't promise that for sure you
know books both writing and publishing
books just takes a really long time i
mean i guess it's been a while
since i published a textbook so it might
be a shorter turnaround time for the
textbook
um because presumably i will write it up
in latex and they will just sort of
um copy edit that file directly rather
than typesetting it and all those things
that the trade books do
but anyway 2022 very very soonest
sorry about that gary miller says
in many worlds theory are there
countless universes that are identical
but for one quantum particle somewhere
in that universe
and wouldn't most of them hew to some
similar mean state because changing a
few particles here and there wouldn't
seem likely to dramatically change an
entire universe even over billions of
years
um yeah absolutely no there's no rule in
many worlds says the worlds are very
very different from each other
one particle being different is unlikely
because
you know typically momentum is conserved
or something like that so
you can say that one particle has
decayed or not decayed
and that absolutely as long as that
decaying particle
becomes entangled with the rest of the
world that would qualify as making a new
universe yeah i think that's part of
many worlds you have to learn to accept
that if that's the route you're going to
go down which i encourage you to do
david asks what implications does
quantum entanglement have for how we
understand
human relationships uh zero
none whatsoever human beings are deeply
within the classical regime
we're not entangled with each other
sorry about that entanglement is not
like a
as we said a physical force pulling us
together pushing us apart anything like
that
it's just a feature of the quantum wave
function that is really inapplicable
to big macroscopic things like human
beings in the real world
on individual branches of the wave
function
gustavo chavez says when you interviewed
tyler cowan in episode 19 i hoped it
would be like a live performance of tom
murphy's delightful
exponential economist meets finite
physicist blog post
in it the author recounts a dinner
conversation between a physicist and an
economist about the hard limitations
physics imposes on the idea of
exponential economic growth
the basic rationale is that our rate of
economic growth so far is always
dependent on equal or higher rate of
energy consumption growth
and that the earth only has one
mechanism for releasing heat
to space and that's via infrared
radiation we understand the phenomenon
perfectly well and can predict the
surface temperature of the planet as a
function of how much energy the human
race produces
the upshot is that a 2.3 growth rate
at a 2.3 growth rate we would reach
boiling temperature in about 400 years
do you agree with that 400 years seems
so soon is there uh
any way out of this fate for us uh so
there's a few things here
i think that i'm not sure if i agree
with it or not i would have to redo the
calculation which is against the rules
of the ama
um and i'm not sure that it's
calculating the right thing well i'm not
sure what it is
calculating uh in particular because i'm
not sure what
is meant by energy consumption or
energy usage i mean
uh if that's just sort of burning fuels
or something like that then that is
that's one thing but
solar energy comes into us and then we
give it back
uh so there's a net zero energy
consumption if we switch entirely to
solar would that count as zero energy
consumption
under this calculation so i'm just not
sure i'm not exactly sure what's going
on
i do think that one could do a kind of
calculation analogous to this
the important thing is is actually guess
what the entropy production
less than the energy consumption you
know energy is conserved
in the universe but we take useful low
entropy forms of energy and turn them
into
useless high entropy forms of energy and
there's different ways you can do that
and there are limits on the efficiency
of doing that so maybe there's some
calculation like that
but i have no intuition for how quickly
we're going to reach that but also
you know this big assumption that the
rate of growth is somehow
exactly proportional to the rate of
energy consumption seems very unlikely
to be true to me
this is why physicists doing economics
is always kind of a shaky thing like you
can derive conclusions from your
assumptions but
it's the assumptions that should be
questioned here
when i was interviewing tyler i you know
i'm not that interested in doing science
fictiony
apply physics ideas to economic stuff i
really wanted to understand
the rationale and the implications of
his idea
that the most moral way to organize an
economy is to maximize growth because
everything else is secondary that seems
that seems like an unrealistic claim to
me but it's interesting to try to
pinpoint
exactly why one thinks that it is
casey haskins says if you were granted
the power to change one thing about the
way academic science is practiced today
what would it be uh you know that's a
hard question to ask i don't necessarily
have
a ready-to-hand answer because academic
science is a very complicated thing with
a lot
of moving parts um let me mention two
things i know you said one thing
let me mention two things that i think
are sort of semi-plausible
changes in the way things could be done
one is in the way that
grants are given out you know science
requires grant money
you needed to pay graduate students you
post docs
traveling you know buying equipment of
course
people not like me but real
experimentalists require
a lot of great money for setting up labs
building experiments things like that
theoretical physicists don't need that
much
but even we need a little for students
and stuff like that
um and it's just a pain to get the grant
money i mean
i think the system works pretty well
it'll never be perfect but having served
on
committees to hand out grant money i i
know
uh from experience that the people on
those committees are really sincerely
committed to trying to make sure that
the best proposals get funded you know
i've absolutely been on
grand proposal committees where some big
shot uh who's very famous and very
successful and very smart
very talented you know kind of phoned in
their grant proposal and basically said
you know
i'm smart give me money whereas a young
person who's also smart uh
put in a grant proposal that really had
some ideas in it and we
funded the young person and not the big
famous person um
but i i really think there's a huge
inefficiency in the fact that just takes
so much time this might be because we're
in grant
renewal season right now at caltech but
there's just so much work
put into this and i don't think it needs
to be for something like theoretical
physics
it's just crazy that we're spending time
because the grand proposal
is set up the whole idea of it is set up
for something much more experimental
where you say well i'm going to
build this thing and then i'm going to
try to do this experiment with it
and that that's a very sensible thing to
ask for a proposal for
but theorists don't know from month to
month what they're going to be working
on
so we have to pretend to say well okay
next year i'm going to do this and the
year after that i'm going to do that
and it's just it's just bizarre and so i
think that you know
there's a certain class of people and
theoretical physicists fit into them but
other people fit into them where you do
a much better job
just asking you know how many
interesting things has the person done
over the last five years have they been
productive have they been doing good
work
if so continue to give them money of
course you have to
um figure out extra categories for brand
new people
young people whatever and there should
also be categories for people who
haven't been doing good work but
do have a good idea and need money to do
it but i think that you know
rolling funding for people who have been
productive over and over again
would both be easier more accurate and
save a lot of time
that's one idea the other idea much more
radical is i think that there should be
universities that don't have departments
in other words every university has a
physics department history department
and economics department
and i think it has even much more of a
chilling effect on interdisciplinary
work
than we talk about you know like and
i've seen this
in action where i'm in a physics
department and we're thinking about
hiring a new person who does biophysics
and rather than asking you know is the
work good we're constantly asking is it
physics really
and the same thing i'm true i'm sure is
true for you know an economic historian
i'm sure that there's an economic
economics department that is saying but
is it really economics and a history
department is saying is it really
history
and there's just a million examples of
this and so i can
envision a utopian university this
doesn't have departments that it has
professors
and professors have their specialties
but rather than
the department deciding to hire people
that sort of continue on their favorite
kind of research there are
ad hoc committees that say like what
kind of person do we want to have here
at the university
and individual students could sort of
carve out their own
specialty in their own major by picking
and choosing different courses to take
that might be too utopian but i think
that something like that you know we
have a lot of universities at least some
place should try it
simon carter says does your work
deriving space-time from quantum
mechanics work for other interpretations
or just many worlds
the answer is i'm not sure it's
certainly a much easier fit
in many worlds than other
interpretations so i'm not going to say
what is or is not
possible in other interpretations but
the thing about many worlds is
exactly because it is so simple and
austere there's just a vector in
hilbert's space evolving with time
it doesn't make a lot of assumptions to
start with about what it is
you're quantizing right whereas as far
as i know
every other version of quantum mechanics
has a vision from the start about what
it is you're quantizing you know
particles or
fields or or whatever and so therefore
you kind of have to know the answer
ahead of time when it comes to quantum
gravity
there's a different kind of thing like
you can start with space time but if
you're saying well space time
isn't the fundamental ingredient if it's
somehow emerging
from something we don't know what it is
then
you're reduced just guessing and that's
what we you know we guess that string
theory is right or loop quantum gravity
is right and then you try that out and
that's perfectly
sensible way of moving forward but it's
not a model independent algorithm for
saying well
here are the properties it would have to
have no matter what the right guess
is that's something that many worlds is
set up to do in a very nice way i think
john says i have a question about
quantum gravity in the double slit
experiment consider an atom on
edge on the edge there's some some
missed typo here an atom on edge of on
the edge of the left slit
and an atom on the edge of the right
slit as an electron passes through both
slits is there any
tug from gravity on these two atoms i
realize
humanity will likely never have
instruments sensitive enough to test
this and then i'm basically asking you
for the correct theory of quantum
gravity
um not necessarily the correct theory of
quantum gravity needed here
[Music]
this is the kind of question you can
certainly imagine asking independently
of the specifics of quantum gravity
uh any theory or quantum gravity better
give you classical gravity in the
correct limit
so um yeah you know i think that there
will be a gravitational pull you know
that's that's the thing about gravity
according to einstein is that everything
causes a gravitational pull
uh you know there's a small number of
contrarians
who think that gravity can be classical
while quantum mechanics will matter and
everything else is still quantum
mechanical
to me that makes absolutely zero sense
because gravity says there's a certain
amount of energy
in some place and that energy causes
space time to curve
but if in quantum mechanics you don't
even know where an object is
you know if it can be the superposition
of being here and being there
then how do you calculate where the
energy is it kind of just doesn't fit
together very much
so i think the gravitational field has
to be quantized and therefore
yeah you'll definitely have a
gravitational impact on the double slit
experiment
when you run the numbers you find the
effect is so tiny that it's never going
to matter like like you say so
no one needs to worry about that there's
other forces just the
just the radiation from light in the
room is enormously greater
than the force due to gravity from an
atom
lou argires says how does a rotating
universe work
do you take a baby big bang and spin it
like a top what is the axis
uh these are all very good questions i
don't think that in fact
the idea of a rotating universe makes
perfect sense you know in other words
there are universes that make perfect
sense or cosmological models that make
perfect sense that people describe as
rotating
but they don't map cleanly on to the
notion of a spinning top that you have
in mind
typically what they what they involve is
something like
galaxies in the universe all
rotate individually or essentially all
galaxies have some rotational axis
what if all those axes were lined up
together right
we think that in the real world the
galaxies sort of have spin axes that are
randomly distributed with respect to
each other or at least far away galaxies
but if they were all lined up that would
sort of impart some
effective average non-zero angular
momentum vector
to the mass in the universe as a whole
um we don't think
that's how it is so there is no axis in
the real world as far
as we know anonymous says could you
explain what temperature is
unlike the usual macroscopic definition
which states that it is a measure of
equality of a state of a material
i'm interested in a microscopic
definition on a particle level can a
single
isolated particle from the standard
model have a temperature well the answer
is basically no
temperature is an emergent feature
of large collections of particles
there's no such thing as the temperature
of a single particle
one classical definition of temperature
is just the average kinetic energy
of particles in a gas so you could you
know the thing that it comes the closest
to the temperature of a single particle
is the kinetic energy
of the particle but it's not really the
the temperature because temperature
implies the idea that different
particles have different relative
kinetic energies for a single particle
the kinetic energy depends on your
reference frame in which you measure it
but the temperature doesn't depend on
the reference frame
so that's okay you know temperature it's
like pressure pressure is exactly the
same way
or uh just density of of matter there
are certain things
that do not make sense at a particle
level but become interesting and
relevant
at the emergent level when you have many
many particles
pat gallagher says is the arrow of time
relativistic
in that different observers may
experience different sequences of events
uh no it's not relativistic in that
sense at least again as far as we know
many of these questions are have a
caveat
as far as we know so in the world as we
know it where there are no time machines
right where there are no closed time
like curves
you can slice the universe into moments
of time
and the arrow of time has as one of its
features that
there's a function of those slices
called the entropy
the entropy of the universe at that
moment of time and it increases
monotonically in a certain direction so
relativity says that there are different
ways of slicing the universe into
moments of time
uh different observers would naturally
define different reference frames
but it remains the case that no matter
how you slice it
according to any observer in the in the
in a universe without close time-like
curves
you will have the feature that entropy
increases monotonically
in the same direction on all of them so
the arrow of time is invariant in that
sense
john eastman says the doomsday argument
assumes that we're we are equally likely
to be born in any position within the
unique list of all humans who will ever
live
but if the many world's interpretation
is correct then our birth position is
simultaneously within many different
lists of humans branching through our
present into different futures
thus our birth position is no longer
correlated with the size of a unique
list of humans and therefore the
doomsday argument
fails is this correct um
i think it's on the right track honestly
but you know look i don't believe the
doomsday argument i think the doomsday
argument does fail so uh
once you think it fails there's probably
more than one reason you think it fails
i think the idea of assuming that we are
typical observers within the
population of all human beings to ever
live is just not a good assumption
we're not i'm not a typical observer i'm
me you know i'm very specific
actual observer um but this is as you'll
recall if you listen to the um podcast
with nick bostrom this is a
controversial issue people are not clear
on the best way to do this
um there's a there's a school of thought
that says
that when you're comparing theories with
large numbers of observers to theories
of cosmology with small numbers of
observers
you should favor the theories that have
large number of observers because it's
more likely you're in that theory than
in the other theory i don't think that's
right
i think that you can favor theories in
which it is more likely that
you specifically you come into existence
so therefore it might effectively be
true that
universes with large numbers of
observers are more likely
but i don't think you should you should
weight your prior probabilities by the
number of observers
if you did think that then you'd get
into a complicated situation
in many worlds because now you have
multiple worlds but they have different
weights right they have different
amplitudes different thicknesses
so i would think that you should then
weight the number of observers
by the amplitude squared or that branch
of the wave function but i don't think
that's the first thing the right thing
to be doing
anyway so i haven't really given a lot
of thought to that
siddhartha says i want to spark yet
another discussion on the question of
free will
my takeaway of your views is the free
will is emergent but we're not laplace's
demon and in our everyday lives we
cannot help but make choices because we
have very incomplete information
but how about free will in the stronger
sense asked another way given the
physical laws and initial conditions of
the universe
was it inevitable that 13.8 billion
years later a biological entity called
sean carroll will experience a series of
life events that will lead him to start
the mindscape podcast and monthly ama
questions
in exactly the manner you have done um
well
you know i think that it's an underposed
question because it depends on what your
view is about the
laws of physics okay um in particular
quantum mechanics kind of gets in the
way here right
you know uh quantum mechanics says that
there are probabilities of different
things happening and if you played
the movie backwards or
re-ran the film of the universe starting
from the beginning again you would not
get the same outcomes and that has
nothing to do with free will whatsoever
it just has
a question of whether or not the laws of
physics are deterministic or
indeterministic
many worlds is deterministic so the
multiverse is the same
but people might be in different
branches of the wave function
experiencing different things so there
is a question about whether or not the
laws of physics are deterministic and
indeterministic
that has zero to do with the question of
free will
the strong sense of free will the
libertarian sense of free will
has to do with whether or not you
personally can violate the laws of
physics
just by thinking about it and i don't
think that's true but whether or not
it's true
uh has nothing to do with whether or not
the laws are deterministic or
indeterministic
a universe governed by indeterministic
laws of physics
has exactly as much free will as the
universe governed by determined laws of
physics
if those laws of physics are always
obeyed even by people
joseph tungretti says i have a hard time
wrapping my head around the notion that
a gravitational field
doesn't decay down to zero given enough
distance between two massive objects
if the only matter in the universe
consisted of two neutrons located a
million light years apart
does general relativity imply that given
enough time they'd move closer and
closer to each other until they
eventually
collide um it does i mean
you need to tell me what the velocity of
the neutrons is if the neutrons start at
rest with respect to each other
then in general relativity or newtonian
gravity or anything else
there's a gravitational pull between
them and they would eventually come
together
neutrons were not a good choice for you
because neutrons decay within like 10
minutes
so it would they would decay long before
they came together
neutrinos would work if you had two
neutrinos at rest that'd be even more
vivid example they're even lighter in
mass and they're stable
but they would eventually pull each
other together yeah
john bach says given the state of the
evidence today would you put your money
on the traditional big bang or the big
bounce
are there some theoretical issues that
the big balance solves that make it more
appealing than the big bang
well you know i don't know i certainly
don't have strong feelings one way or
the other i don't think that the big
bounce is the right way to
talk about the alternatives to the big
bang i mean presumably by big bounce you
mean the universe that
collapses and then bounces and we're in
the expanding phase
if that only happens once then
it's almost impossible to solve what i
think is the most important problem
which is where the arrow of time comes
from why the entropy was so low near
that bounce
if it happens cyclically many times then
that problem is even worse because
you're pushing it back to t
equals minus infinity so i don't like
bouncing cosmologies very much at all
for exactly that reason
but you can have other ways in which
there is space time
before the big bang but just not a
bounce and that's what
jennifer chen and i proposed in 2004
where baby universes could spontaneously
nucleate
out of an empty space-time pre-existing
so i think that
i'm very open on the question of whether
or not there was a universe and
space-time before the big bang
but the specific scenarios of bouncing
cosmologies
uh i'm not a big fan of brent meeker
says in posing the black hole
information paradox it is commonly noted
that hawking showed the radiation
spectrum to be a black body
and then it is inferred that the
outgoing radiation can contain no
information
except the temperature parameter of the
planck spectrum this seems like a big
leap to me is there no way to have a
blackbody spectrum that is not produced
by an array of random
radiators so yeah this is just a case
of sloppy science communication to be
honest
so it's not true that hawking shows that
the spectrum of radiation is the black
body
and then we infer from that that there's
no information in the outgoing radiation
what hawking actually infers in his
calculation is the specific
state of the outgoing radiation namely
that is a
thermal density matrix so if that
doesn't mean anything to you
it means that the wave function of the
individual of the set of all the
radiation particles
is not a pure single wave function it's
a mixture of multiple
possible wave functions in exactly the
same way
that in ordinary statistical mechanics
we talk about the probability
distribution of particles in a box to
have certain velocities
and positions we talk about the
probability distribution for the quantum
state to be in different wave functions
and the thermal and so that whole thing
that mixed state as we call it a
combination
of many different wave functions is
called a density matrix okay
for technical reasons which you don't
have to get into but there is a specific
density matrix
called the thermal density matrix which
is something that has the spectrum of a
black body
and no other information in it that is
the
status that is the the characteristic
feature of the thermal density matrix
and that's what hawking's calculation
predicts the photons should be in so
hawking's calculation doesn't just
predict that the spectrum should be a
blackbody
it predicts specifically that there is
no information
hidden in secret correlations in the
outgoing photons
and that's why people don't believe that
hawking's radiation is the right final
answer
if you believe that information
eventually gets out you need
you need to actually have secret
correlations in that outgoing set of
photons
while still having the spectrum of a
black body but not exactly a thermal
density matrix
a morris says does the expansion of the
universe affect the wave functions of
electrons and other elementary particles
in other words do these particles
experience a kind of redshift like
photons do and if so what is the
practical effect
um i think the answer is it depends you
know it's this these are hard questions
to answer because
we talk in words about the expansion of
the universe
um but it's the equations that matter
right
so the correct answer to any equation
like this any question
like this is give me the equation
for the physical system you want to
describe like
the wave function of an electron or
something like that
couple it to the expanding universe
metric tensor of general relativity and
solve for its behavior
okay and then the answer is given to you
full stop
um for photons you do you do that i mean
you can pick up my general relativity
book we do that for photons and that's
where you get
you're solving maxwell's equation for
the uh evolution of photons because
they're electromagnetic waves so it's
not photon particles it's classical
electromagnetic waves and that's where
the redshift comes from
so what you would want to do is take the
schrodinger equation for the wave
function of an electron
and allow it to be evolving
in the background of an expanding
universe and i'm sort of hemming and
haunting about what the actual answer is
because it depends
on what's going on it with the condition
of your particle
if it's just one particle okay if it's
just the wave function of an electron
it has nothing whether or not the
universe is expanding the
that electrons wave function will spread
out this is what wave functions do they
spread out okay so a um
a a plane wave will
be spread out all throughout the
universe right but that's just
uh uh what what should i say it's an
idealization right
so you can have a plane wave that is
oscillating like a perfect sine wave
spread out all throughout space but
that's not as we already talked about
earlier a normalized wave function
okay so to create what we call a wave
packet
which is a wave function or any other
wave that is
localized in space with different uh
wiggles in it
that wave packet can be thought of as a
superposition
of parts of energy that move at
different velocities
so all this is to say in a fancy way
that if you start with a wave packet for
an electron or a photon or anything else
it will spread out over time okay
so that's not quite the cosmological
redshift the equivalent of cosmological
redshift
for something like an electron a massive
particle
is just that its momentum changes right
if you
if you instead of emitting a photon from
one galaxy to another one
if you throw a photon throw not a photon
photons always move the speed of light
throw an electron or throw a baseball
for that matter
from one galaxy to another and you set
it up so that in the rest frame of the
throwing it has a certain momentum
then in the rest frame of the person
catching it in the other galaxy its
momentum will be
less and that will be because of the
cosmological redshift
so there are debates i'll admit it there
are debates in the general relativity
literature about whether or not that's
really a different thing than the
ordinary doppler shift
i think it is but at some level you can
absolutely predict
everyone agrees on the prediction of
what you observe right all they disagree
about is whether or not it's worth
attaching certain words to it
and that i feel less strongly about
personally jared kasulich
says if there were two of you and you
could coordinate your activities to
learn from each other how would the
other you
spend their time um so i think in these
questions
you know i i it's related to my thoughts
about many worlds
if there are two of me there aren't two
of me
there are two different people who might
be identical they might
both look like me and have the same
memories as me and all that stuff but
they're two people
so it's not like you know uh calvin and
kelvin and hobbes where you duplicate
yourself and have all your duplicates do
the messy work do your homework and do
the dishes and things like that because
those are people and
they they live a life too so there's no
sense in which
it's fair to like make one person do all
the learning and the other person just
goof off and have a good time that's
because there's two different people
uh so i think that what you're asking is
you know could we
um split up the responsibilities and the
fun equally or something like that but
honestly i don't know i'm so
i'm a little worried that these sort of
thought experiment questions are
uh not tied down by reality well enough
uh so i'm not trying to avoid your
question
but i honestly don't know how to answer
it in an honest way sorry about that
scott fenton says what do you think our
best physical theories
sorry why do you think our best physical
theories still rely on constants of
nature
and to what degree is progress in
physics related to elimination or
sublimation of physical constants
it seems that major paradigm shifts
often come with new ways of seeing
reducing the number of required
constants
um so i'm not sure that's true
that i mean i know there are some times
when you can reduce the number of
required constants so like
when all you knew about was chemistry
and you knew about elements you had to
separately specify all the chemical
elements right and their masses and
their charges
um isotopic abundances things like that
and certainly you know understanding it
was just protons and neutrons uh
made your life a lot easier and the
fundamental theory has fewer constants
in it
but then you know we went and found the
muon and the top quark and the higgs
boson and they require more constants to
uh to specify their details so i don't
have
any special feeling that the best theory
would have no constants or something
like that i mean that would be nice
if there was a way to just from pure
numerology i guess uh derive all the
constants of nature
but we don't we're not anywhere close to
like that happening anytime
soon so i think you should just be
open-minded when you're moving from
our current theories to better theories
whether or not the number of
parameters or constants of nature will
increase or decrease i think
that's not something we have the right
to guess right now
uh wes clyburn says who was your
favorite muppet
um you know i'm of an age
those of you i hope that there's some of
you out there that are of the same age
my experience with the muppets was
mostly from sesame street you know my my
muppet watching years as it were
was before the muppets had their own tv
show but i mean probably i could have
watched the muppet show and did but it
wasn't like one of my favorite things
when i was a
young kid it was definitely sesame
street that i was watching so
i think that do the big ones count like
do the human beings in costumes count as
muppets i'm not sure because if that's
allowed
then i will definitely vote for
snuffleupacus to be my favorite muppet i
always liked it when he was on the show
he rarely appeared
and of course none of the humans on the
show could see him so i thought that was
cool
michael lacy says in last month's ama
you said that there would be many
branches of the wave function in which
donald trump was not re-elected
if branching is caused by quantum
decoherence but human behavior can be
explained using classical physics
what would cause branches to have
different election results would
differences result from a schrodinger's
cat scenario where a quantum measurement
can trigger different macroscopic
outcomes
or would they result from a butterfly
effect where very small differences in
the initial conditions of each branch
evolve into large differences over time
well
um i want to say both because those two
things are not really different from
each other you know the schrodinger's
cat scenario
is exactly set up so as
to take a tiny quantum measurement
outcome and amplify it to a big
macroscopic difference
cat's alive or cat's dead or gets awake
or cats to sleep however you want to do
it
so that is what is needed for any of
these things to be true so if you want
a quantum fluctuation where a whole
bunch of people vote differently for
example
uh that could happen by you know random
but
um coordinated changes in the brains of
a whole bunch of voters
right um and it's unlikely but it
absolutely could happen one way or the
other
so my thing about human choices and
quantum branchings is you know i
i keep thinking that i say it very
clearly but people not
not you michael but people keep
misunderstanding me so let me say it
again
what i try to say is human choices do
not cause branching
but branching can absolutely cause human
choices okay
in other words quantum events like a
certain chemical reaction
not happening even though it's
overwhelmingly likely that it happens
but maybe there's a quantum fluctuation
and it doesn't happen
we could interpret the effects of that
in the macroscopic world as a different
decision being made
by a human being okay because human
beings are just collections of particles
obeying the rules of quantum physics
so it's not that we could we
can never have different branches which
we would interpret x post facto
as saying well different decisions were
made on these branches my point is
simply that
the branching was not caused by the
decision making it's the other way
around
james kittik says reversibility in
principle versus reversibility in
practice
is sometimes explained through examples
like scrambling an egg
but i got to thinking about a line of
dominoes set up on a table when the
dominoes get
get knocked down by a chain reaction i'm
struggling to see how this is reversible
even in principle for at least two
reasons so there's two reasons i'm just
gonna read one because i think it's the
same answer for both
the reason is how would the last domino
ever stand up again well i can imagine
some random fluctuations of the atoms in
the table somehow conspiring to give the
domino an upward push
my understanding is that waste heat
can't do work so how would there be
enough energy
to stand the domino back up so i think
the the reason why you can't understand
it is because you're using a rule from
macroscopic physics
waste heat can't do work and trying to
apply it
to a wildly improbable microscopic
situation
in which a huge number of atoms randomly
fluctuate
their velocities in just such a way as
to push a domino back up
so the point is if you allow yourself to
imagine these very very far-fetched
microscopic scenarios
there's no such thing as waste heat
anymore all there is is
atoms right from the this microscopic
point of view there are atoms and they
have velocities and they have positions
and to reverse something like a domino
falling like you don't need a whole
bunch of dominoes just take
one domino it falls and it makes noise
and you say well
how in the world could that domino just
spontaneously pop back
up well when it fell you know it created
noise it created heat it shook
the atoms in the table and in the air
around it
so just wait a second after it fell and
then
thought experiment wise you could never
do this in practice but in principle
imagine reversing the momentum of every
single atom
so you just send it backwards that's all
you need to do
and that is an extremely incredibly
precisely finely tuned
situation but in that situation all
those atoms would come up
and exactly undo the falling of the
domino to put it exactly back up
stationary where it started it's not
very likely but it could happen
christoph pyronsky says we programmers
care tend to care for code efficiency
many worlds interpretation requires
copies of the full universe for the
tiniest differences in single quantum
outcomes
it's almost not possible to imagine
something less efficient
would it be possible to devise a
variation on many worlds which would
keep most of the universe in a single
copy and branch just different results
of quantum
outcomes so i think that this is a
little bit backwards i think that uh
programmers who care for co-deficiency
should be the biggest fans of the many
worlds interpretation of quantum
mechanics because
the code is not the universe's the code
is the schrodinger equation right
the code is not the outcome of doing the
calculation you should distinguish
between the code and the output of the
calculation
i could write a very short code that
gives a
huge output right i could just list all
the real numbers or
well i couldn't do that i could list all
the integers in principle
or the integers up to some bound
whatever you wanted to do with a
very very short amount of code that's
what many worlds is
the code is extremely short there's a
wave function and there's the
schrodinger equation how
how short could you be how more
efficient could you possibly be
um so that's the point that there are
plenty of other variations of many
worlds but their
code their instruction manual is always
less efficient because it says it's
because many world says
there's a wave function and there's the
schrodinger equation every other version
says there's a wave function and the
schrodinger equation and there's this
other stuff that stops other worlds from
being made
so that's where you have to take your
choices
guillermo lc says can shadows travel
faster than the speed of light
and the idea here is this is a kind of a
famous thing you know like if you
if you cast a shadow on something very
very far away like the moon
cast a shadow on the moon um you can
move it back and forth
much faster than the speed of light and
for that matter you don't need to think
about shadows just take a laser and
point it at the moon
you jiggle it back and forth across the
face of the moon and yes
the place where the laser hits the moon
or the edge of a shadow being cast on
the moon
can move faster than the speed of light
because it's not a thing
it's not a thing that can convey
information or any no individual
particles or other things are actually
moving faster than the speed of light in
that experiment but the edge of the
shadow or the point of the laser
absolutely can appear
to be doing that josh says how did the
scientific community treat verner
heisenberg after world war ii was he
able to reintegrate into the scientific
community
um yeah he absolutely was you know i'm
not the best person to ask about the
history of some of these things like
honestly
you know no false modesty here you would
do better just going to the wikipedia
page for verner heisenberg
but he absolutely was still part of the
scientific community
um after world war ii in fact he was a
big deal
you know especially in germany and you
know he served as the director of
various institutes and you know various
international
meetings and things like that so he
absolutely was part of it
um you know i think we have a slightly
different view now because it is much
they didn't know in the 1950s or 60s
that heisenberg had tried really hard
to build an atomic weapon for the for
germany during world war ii
um so that wasn't counted against him
now it was
you know you can ask well what is what
were his spoken opinions about
uh what was going on and i'm again
not the world's best person to ask about
this my
impression is that heisenberg like many
people sort of danced
carefully along an edge of saying you
know i'm not
really for the nazis but on the other
hand
we're in a war and i would rather
germany win the war than the other side
you know in particular a lot of germans
um were very worried that the russians
that the soviets would win the war
and take over and install communism or
something like that so i think that's
where
heisenberg came down but that left him
after the war
not being treated as you know a nasty
ex-nazi just you know
a german who had been too patriotic like
many others had
i'm not passing any judgments and i'm
sure that uh my
information and knowledge here uh is not
very detailed so again you should check
better sources than me linear maziara
says
in something deeply hidden you taught us
a perfectly good explanation for the
born rule
that it makes sense if we understand in
terms of the pythagoras theorem
why can't david albert accept it would
be really the most reasonable
explanation for self-locating
probability in many worlds
so you know there's david albert's
objection you can see it in the
podcast i did with him we had a more
recent youtube
dialogue that you can also check out um
his you know he david knows perfectly
well
that there is a natural measure to put
on your credences
in many worlds given by the born rule he
just doesn't see
what forces you to do that right so i
think
that david has a view of the philosophy
of probability
in which is more frequentest in
orientation
than bayesian uh more objectively chancy
rather than
um subjective and knowledge based so
he doesn't think it's a probability when
you have this situation where there's
one person
on one branch and one person on the
other branch that's not the kind of
thing
that adapts itself to be thought of as
the frequency of an experiment done over
and over again okay because no matter
how many times you branch the wave
function
any up any possible set of outcomes will
be experienced by somebody
so david's objection is not that
pythagoras's theorem doesn't give you
the right answer is that he doesn't
think there is such a thing as
an answer that everyone should be
obligated to use i disagree with him
obviously
but you know different plenty of people
agree with him so there you go
santiago torres says no question this
time merry christmas thanks for your
great podcasts
usually you know people do leave little
messages here in the ama
and i appreciate all of them and i read
all of them but i usually don't read
them out loud
as questions but i thought that you know
just a nice merry christmas to everyone
out there
it was a nice thing to do so i'm reading
this out loud merry christmas
happy hanukkah happy kwanzaa happy
what what did the romans call it the
saturnalia right all sorts of holidays
happen over
uh this time of year and i hope everyone
out there listening has some good ones
joy kolbeck says have you ever spent
christmas outside of the united states
and if so where
if not where in the world would you like
to have a christmas holiday and why
um i don't think that i've ever spent uh
christmas outside the u.s
you know in fact this is going to be the
first year uh the first christmas of my
life that i've not spent it with my mom
um almost always i go to visit her
sometimes she's come to visit me
but um she's in florida and i'm in
california and we're in the middle of a
pandemic
and uh it's it's bursting out all over
and airports and air travel is
especially bad right
now so we have made mutually a mutual
decision to not do it this year
we'll make it up later don't feel bad
for us we can celebrate christmas some
other day
but um therefore no i'm not really been
outside the united states to celebrate
it
um if i did where would i want to do it
you know i think that for something like
christmas
which i absolutely enjoy as a secular
holiday
um i would like to be someplace that
wasn't
too exotic because you know i love
visiting exotic places but look you know
that
it takes a certain energy right it takes
a certain um amount of effort
uh to to sort of uh negotiate places
where you don't speak the language and
you have no idea what's going on
and so that's a fun thing to do but it
doesn't seem very christmassy to me
and i think that christmas also i
wouldn't want
to be in a very warm climate especially
if i'm traveling for a holiday like i
love being in los angeles for christmas
and it's
beautiful every day and go walk outside
without wearing a coat
but if i'm actually traveling somewhere
specifically for christmas
then a little you know snow or at least
chill in the air would be nice
so i'm thinking given that uh probably
some place like london
or edinburgh is one of our favorite
cities i would love to go in edinburgh
and
uh visit the highlands and so forth in
the middle of december that sounds like
it would be great
um uh you know there's plenty of places
that i know and love
montreal paris would all be good places
to go so
no immediate plans to do that but it's
something fun to think about
jessica napier says both determinism and
simulation theory come up quite a bit in
your conversations the former makes me
feel melancholic
and unmotivated and the latter freaked
out you don't seem phased by either
though do you have any words of comfort
or advice
um i think that again i try to give the
short answer and then delve in the short
answer is no
i don't have any special words of
comfort or advice
uh not because i don't think you should
be comforted but because
i was never close to being unmotivated
or melancholic or freaked out by these
things i
you know the there's
your life and how you experience it and
how you live it and how the people
around you experience it and live it
and there's what you learn about the
larger universe right
and if i learn that you know god exists
or god doesn't exist or determinism is
true or indeterminism is true or there's
a multiverse or there's spokesman brains
all that
none of that is directly affecting uh my
actual life i mean maybe god existing
would affect my life if it were some
specific religion that gave me
instructions okay that's true
but sort of a non-interventionist god
out there who just created the universe
and left it alone wouldn't affect my
life at all so
why should that freak me out you know i
think that the powers that i have
uh to affect things at this higher
emergent level where i'm a person making
decisions and affecting things
seem to me the same in all these
different scenarios as they were
before um i think that the only reason
why you might be freaked out
is if you had some maybe subconscious
intuitive feeling of something like
a strong form of libertarian free will
right where you thought of yourself as
not part of the physical world
but as something that was sort of
special and separate and i don't mean
that in a disparaging way plenty of
people
think this going back to well kant
obviously imani will count famously but
going back much further than that
um but i never was tempted by that point
of view i always thought of myself as
part of the universe i'm trying to
understand a little bit better
but the fact that i you know my atoms
are obeying the laws of physics
whether i like it or not uh never
threatened me
never threatened to make me melancholic
or freaked out pablo's papa jordu
says please choose one and then pablos
you've typed physics but then you you
didn't type another one you didn't give
me
any other options so like physics or
nothing i think you just left it out so
i'm just mentioning this
maybe next time we get an ama you should
finish the question
robert grenise says in order for
particles to become entangled do they
have to at some point be near each other
well this is a yes or no question um
the short answer here is no they do not
certainly the existence of entanglement
has nothing to do with the distance
between different particles and as i've
said already earlier in this ama
entanglement doesn't fade away with
either space or time
necessarily it can if you bump into it
the footnote here is that of course
entanglement is caused by some physical
process and the laws of physics are
local
right particles um interact with each
other
when they are at the same point in
space-time not when they're very very
far away
of course two objects like the earth and
the sun can interact with each other
when they're far away but only by the
intermediary of a local field
the gravitational field separate
stretching between them
so that's the secret so you might say
well in order to become entangled
particles have to interact therefore
they have to be at the same place or at
least near each other
but that's not quite right if particle a
wants to become
entangled with particle b it could do
that by particle c
interacting with a and then interacting
with b right
so there could be some other particles
that that
take the entanglement and stretch it
between them
so you could entangle a with c and then
move
c across the universe or whatever and
then c becomes
transfers its entanglement to b in fact
that's actually
something very much like that happens in
what is called quantum teleportation
okay so if you if you google quantum
teleportation you can see things like
that
in action gerald gerard royvan
says i don't know but i read on the
internet that the earth is flat
and here you are telling us there's a
universe and fields and something called
space-time
that's probably your opinion but the
internet tells us different things so
why do you tell
all these fairy tales to the public well
you know it's all just a lie
it could be that you skipped my question
yet i hope you'll know it's not a
serious question
but i wonder how you feel as a person
and a scientist about these kinds of
remarks
about people who believe in all
sincerity that the earth is flat and
things like that
well you know look i have a mixed set of
feelings here because i think that
scientists
um see people getting science wrong
and they both take it too personally and
also
take it too simplistically you know the
fact that people have
incorrect opinions about science whether
it's the earth or flat or anything else
um i don't want to excuse it i don't
want to tell them that it's right to do
that
but it's usually not a straightforward
matter of scientific
literacy uh if anything that we should
have learned in the past
couple decades it's that people's
beliefs about things do not flow
directly from knowledge to belief right
there's plenty of things that go into
forming people's beliefs
um it could be their political
polarization affiliation but it could
also be
where they grew up their feelings about
all sorts of things you know where
we tend to believe things that are said
by people we trust disbelieve things
that are said by people we don't like
there's a whole bunch of things going on
here and i think that
you know a classic example was the
creationism debates
uh that were very strong in the 80s and
90s and so forth
um people were trying to get creationism
taught in public schools and scientists
fought against it
in a way that was you know took it
seriously
as like well these people believe this
view of the world we have this view of
the world let's debate them on the
merits
but they didn't understand that for
a lot of local school districts that
were actually interested
in teaching creationism the people there
couldn't care less about creationism or
darwinism
what they wanted was to not be told what
to think
by a bunch of elites from big cities and
coasts and universities and things like
that
and so in response what the what the
scientists did is to talk down to them
as big city elites right and so it
usually backfires in that way i think
that at least some large fraction of
people who believe the earth is flat
don't really care if the earth is flat
in some very real sense
they are performatively expressing their
distrust of institutions
okay if you want to put it in uh
slightly
uh pompous terminology they're rejecting
the idea that they should be
told what to think uh the ex the the
thing about the earth being flat or
round is not that they have
some idea based on um experiments or
observations
it's that they want to reject the
conventional wisdom
okay and that's also bad but it's bad
for a different reason than
oh these people just haven't been taught
science okay so we we have to think
about
is where trust in scientists comes from
in addition to thinking about where
scientific knowledge comes from and how
we share that
so that's how i feel i feel that we
really need to do
more not only in informing people about
science
but in getting people to trust the right
sources
and distrust the sources they should be
distrusting
matt faw says einstein said that speed
is measured relative to one's frame of
reference and general relativity allows
for frame dragging
the moving of space-time around a
spinning massive body
so is it possible that when vera rubin
saw
what vera rubin saw were galaxies in
which their local frame of reference
itself was moving
relative to us so no because
what einstein said is that inertial
trajectories
unaccelerated trajectories are all
equivalent to each other
in special relativity okay
so speed is measured relative to one's
frame of reference that's true but when
someone like vera rubin
looks at the uh rotation curve of a
spiral galaxy
it's not just measuring the speed of one
particle right
you're measuring the rotation of a
galaxy
and that's a real physical thing that's
not dependent on one's frame of
reference whether a galaxy is rotating
or not rotating is an absolute thing
you know this is isaac newton's famous
bucket experiment
you can take a bucket and you can spin
it and
you can instantly observe the fact that
it is spinning
from the fact that the water in the
bucket begins to creep up the edges
of the bucket what that means is there's
a real physical effect
of that spinning so that is not
something that simply depends on one's
perspective so
there's a long-winded way of saying that
when you are measuring
the velocities of stars or
radioactive uh not radioactive uh using
radio waves to measure the gas and dust
inside galaxies you're measuring a real
physical thing
not a uh frame dependent thing
tom hawkins says do you think that
spending sending humans to the moon and
mars is a wise use of resources
or would it be better to continue with
robotic exploration
well you know robotic exploration is
absolutely more cost effective
okay so uh you know i'm very bad at
answering questions about how we should
divide up the money
uh because i'm not sure how much money
we have you know it's not something that
i'm really well
in um or how best to spend it or things
like that
it's certainly true i'm happy to say
that for given
scientific return robotic exploration
in the solar system is currently way
more cost effective than sending human
beings
but look i get the fact that sending
human beings has a romantic
side to it you know forget about cost
effectiveness the world is not all cost
effectiveness or we just wouldn't send
robots at all like just stay here on
earth right
we have this drive to understand things
we also separately
and you know coincidentally and and uh
synchronously have a desire to go there
and that's okay so i'm all in favor of
human exploration of the solar system
i just don't want it to cut into the
budget for scientific exploration which
is
cheaper to do just using robots dan
inch says i understand that some people
in the u.s declaw their cats
this is unheard of here in the uk and i
think it's actually illegal without
passing judgment are your cats declawed
uh so no ariel and galban very much had
their claws
you can see the evidence for that on my
legs and arms
they're very very sweet cats and you
know they would never
strike out in anger but they do
sometimes get spooked
and clawing happens right so yeah you
know look i grew up
um with cats and some of them were
declawed you know when uh when i was a
kid when i was not the decision maker in
the family but also
i'm not i'm not sure what um you know
the the
state of of knowledge about declawing
was at the time you know now i
understand
that it is a bad thing to do and you
know i think that when you get cats on
the one hand i i'm
made happy by people adopting cats from
their local shelter
etc but on the other hand it's a
responsibility right like
you have to take the good with the bad
you have to take care of the cats
they're they're
depending on you now and so part of that
is you know
the cats are going to cloth some things
like again ariel and caliban are
actually
incredibly well behaved compared to many
cats i grew up with cats i know what i'm
talking about
our furniture is in very good shape they
do not claw on the furniture they do not
try to eat human food uh you know we can
sit there eating dinner
fish chicken whatever and you know they
can they'll walk around they don't even
try
to eat it from us they don't usually
knock things off
of desks and tables ariel sometimes does
that strategy but again
less often than my other cats did so but
you don't know right
if they had grown up with different
personalities where they were clawing
the furniture all the time you know we
would try to dissuade them from doing it
but yeah you have to live with that
that's a decision you have to accept
blake sewer says as a mechanical
engineer i had myriad classes in
classical thermodynamics
but i never really developed an
intuitive feel for the field until i
studied
statistical mechanics why don't we start
with that
statistical mechanics so thermodynamics
is the
you know science that arose in the first
half of the
1800s with ideas like entropy
and work and the efficiency of different
heat
transfers and so forth whereas
statistical mechanics which arose in the
second half
of the 1800s was about
explaining all of those features of
thermodynamics
by thinking of fluids and gases as
actually made of atoms made of made of
particles made of molecules
which had a statistical distribution of
their velocities and so forth
thus statistical mechanics so yeah i
mean i
i sympathize with the idea that
there are certain intuitive
understandings that you get from
statistical mechanics
and it is after all true but there are
things that are
very understandable in terms of
thermodynamics that you just
don't need all that uh machinery to get
right i mean the ideal gas law pressure
times velocity
is proportional to the temperature right
times the amount of stuff
that's a simple thing you can understand
you can understand
why a gas inside a piston heats up when
you push it
without going into details about atoms
and distribution functions and things
like that
so it's always a choice when you teach
physics so when you learn physics
do you do it exactly right from the very
start
or do you you know take a level of
analysis
and study that and then then learn later
about a deeper level of analysis
i do not think that you should teach
quantum mechanics first
and classical mechanics just take the
limit to quantum mechanics i just think
that
would be i mean quantum mechanics is
harder than classical mechanics why not
give people classical mechanics right
away and i think that it
it's a less clear case i admit with
thermodynamics and statmec
but i do think that you can learn some
things about thermodynamics
perfectly well without knowing statmak
look if you really want to understand
thermodynamics you need to study
differential geometry
that's the secret they don't tell you um
if you really want to know like where
are all these partial derivatives coming
from
and all these rules and it doesn't make
sense it's all because the secret of
thermodynamics is thinking of it as
different coordinate systems in a high
dimensional manifold
right all those partial derivatives and
maxwell relations
are just super simple in the language of
differential geometry
but no one learns differential geometry
first and then thermodynamics
second okay so in fact most people learn
thermodynamics then never learn
differential geometry so you always
make those sort of sacrifices when you
learn things in the real world
chris fautash says is the universe
finite or infinite
and if the answer is infinite since it
started from a singularity with a finite
shape at one point did it become
infinite so we don't know whether the
universe is finite or infinite we
honestly don't know
so it's not like i'm hiding anything
from you it might be finite it might be
infinite we just
don't know there's only a finite amount
of it that we can observe but that tells
us nothing
about whether or not the part outside is
finite or infinite um
and you say if the answer is infinite if
it started from singularity with a
finite shape
at one point did it become infinite but
it didn't if the universe is infinite it
did not start from a singularity with a
finite
shape if the universe was infinite it
was always infinite
okay so i've said before maybe
you've heard me talk about this before
or not but
the big bang the singularity at the
beginning of cosmology
is just a place where we don't know
what's going on we don't even have the
language to talk about it
classical general relativity fails okay
so the singularity itself is not
something we have any right to
proclaim knowledge about all we can talk
about with any sensibility
is a certain amount of time even even if
it's a very short amount of time but
some amount of time
after the singularity and the point is
in big bang cosmologies
in solutions to einstein's equations of
general relativity that come from an
initial singularity
um there are plenty of solutions of the
form
where at every single moment
after the big bang singularity space is
infinitely big
there's just no problem with that and
that's one of the features of general
relativity that there's no problem with
that you can have space
infinitely big richard young says i
understand that the universe in many
worlds only branches
when quantum systems and superpositions
become entangled with their environment
but i wonder about something like a
large hadron collider where we monitor
almost countless resolutions of quantum
entanglement
uh in an experiment like atlas does each
resolution of a particle's path or decay
cause a branching
uh yeah absolutely it does i mean
but again that's not that many compared
to other things going on in the universe
there's a lot
of specific things going on so think of
it this way you know when
a uh when when two particles crash into
each other in a particle physics
experiment
the prediction of quantum mechanics is
that the wave functions of the new
particles being made
move out away from that collision in
more or less a spherical
wave okay not exactly in fact depending
on the details it might not even be
close to that but in principle
it could be moving out in all directions
that's never what you see
what you see is a trajectory a curve of
a
actual particle in your detector and
this goes all the way back
uh this was in fact called someone's
someone's paradox or someone's puzzle
uh i forget the guy's name but you know
back in the early days of quantum
mechanics the predictions of the
schrodinger equation was that
when a uh an atom decays a radioactive
decay
the electron or whatever alpha particle
that gets emitted
has a wave function that is emitted in a
spherical
um wave but you never observe that you
observe a track
and the many worlds explanation for that
is as soon as
that wave function interacts with the
detector around it
it branches it branches into many many
different copies and in every different
copy
the wave function is the the particles
observed to be
in a particular place going in a certain
direction the good news is that once
that happens once that initial branching
happens
and you have now a localized wave packet
in that branch
where the particle has been detected at
a particular place and it's moving in a
certain direction
then it just keeps bumping into the rest
of the
detector and leaving a track and you can
show this you know using math
so the fact that you see a line
corresponding to the trajectory of a
particle
isn't surprising even in many worlds but
yes there's a lot of branching
just like there is with all sorts of
other radioactive decays
simon tallock says why doesn't the
cosmic
microwave background radiation give us a
universal standard of rest
against which all velocities can be
measured absolutely
it does in fact we call it the
cosmological rest frame this is
something that cosmologists talk about
all the time and
i i know i think i know what's in the
back of your mind namely what's in the
back of your mind is
aren't we taught that there is no
absolute rest frame but what really
again you know there's details that get
left out sometimes when we talk about
these things the real thing
is the vacuum empty space
space-time itself doesn't have a rest
frame
okay the fact that the universe is full
of photons in the form of the cosmic
microwave background
and we can measure our rest frame with
respect to that is no
different than saying i can measure the
velocity of
my car with respect to the ground okay
of course
individual objects in the universe can
define the standard of rest with respect
to them
and it just so happens that
cosmologically we have one that we can
share all over the universe but it
doesn't affect the features of
relativity that in empty space the laws
of physics
don't depend on your velocity with
respect to anything at all
siraj rajan says is hilbert's space a
real thing
or is it something invented for the math
of physics to work what is a good
analogy you use to explain it to someone
at an undergrad level
you know i never know exactly what to
how to answer these questions because
they
involve deep questions in the philosophy
of mathematics that i don't have strong
opinions about
um you know in some sense what i'm
tempted to say but i won't stand up
to uh absolute belief in it because i'm
not an expert at this
what i'm tempted to say is hilbert's
base is an abstract idea
there's only one real thing which is the
universe or the other real things are
things inside the universe or parts of
the universe or aspects of the universe
okay
in our way of thinking about quantum
mechanics
hilbert space is the space of all
possible wave functions
uh it has the mathematical character of
a vector space
as jon von neumann pointed out a long
time ago and
so even in that perspective even if we
wanted to think of
the universe as a wave function it's
only one vector there's only one element
of a
hilbert's base which has an infinite
number of elements so the whole hilbert
space doesn't exist at least not at any
one time
but of course there are people
mathematical platonists who think that
abstract mathematical
objects do exist have a sense of
existence
separate from the kind of existence that
physical stuff
has so i don't necessarily buy into that
but very very smart people do
so if you are a mathematical platonist
then hilbert's space exists
otherwise it's a mathematical tool that
we use to understand the real physical
world which is what actually exists
dead baby seal says i have been starting
to learn a little bit about quantum
field theory and to be honest
canonical quantization feels sort of
arbitrary
do we know of other ways of performing
quantization in qft if so are they
useful and what are they used for
uh so yeah there's absolutely other ways
uh in quantum field theory or not in
quantum field theory right you can
do things via path integral that's a
different thing than canonical
quantization
um there's other sort of operator based
methods and things like that
but you know in some ways i want to say
who cares right i've said this before
i'm going to say it again
nature doesn't start with classical
theories and quantize them
the idea of quantization is a way of
discovering
quantum mechanical theories but the
quantum mechanical theories exist all by
themselves however you go about
discovering them
even when you do canonical quantization
you're still there's still some
arbitrariness
in how you go ordering order
operator ordering ambiguities and and
things like that
uh but hopefully you know most of the
time you get more or less the same
answer and that's true
in quantum field theory so different
yeah different textbooks will use
different ways of doing it but you'll
end up in the same place more or less
with qft
jan lucic says is the universe 13.8
billion years old
everywhere or just from our local
perspective
well i don't know about everywhere you
know again we can only observe
part of the universe some finite bit of
it outside the part we can observe
things might be very very different
including um
the the big bang and all that associated
with that
um also as we've been there's been a
bunch of special relativity questions
here
just saying the universe 13.8 billion
years old everywhere
implies a certain choice of reference
frame in fact it's the reference frame
given to us by the cosmic background
radiation the cosmic rest frame okay
in that rest frame from that perspective
the statement that the universe is 13.8
billion years old is just the statement
that
the time from now in that rest frame
to the big bang is 13.8 billion years
from the perspective of every particle
that is at rest in that rest frame
and roughly speaking that means all the
massive particles in the universe right
particles don't travel near the speed of
light if they move a little bit
it doesn't affect their perception of
time very much so
13.8 billion years old everywhere in the
visible universe is a perfectly
legitimate thing to say
christopher stanford says does time stop
in a black hole
it would have its own laws of nature
within its own confines its own universe
so no time does not stop in a black hole
um at least as far as we know no one's
been inside a black hole so what do we
know we could get burned up by a
firewall when we come
close but according to the standard
theory of black holes and general
relativity etc if you
pass by the event horizon or in a black
hole time still flows for you you might
not even notice if the black hole's big
enough
you wouldn't even notice that you were
inside a black hole
steve m says what do we know about the
higgs field beyond its existence
and the boson can it be affected as we
affect the electromagnetic field
giving mass to particles doesn't tell me
much uh
yeah of course it can be affected just
as we affect the electromagnetic field
it is a field out there and affecting it
is how we discovered it at the large
hadron collider when we
collide quarks together that are inside
um protons they started the higgs field
vibrating and we saw that as a
excitation of the higgs field and
detected its decay products that's how
we know that it's there
the problem is that unlike the
electromagnetic field the higgs is very
massive okay so when a particle is
mass less like the photon the particle
associated with the electromagnetic
field what that means is you know we've
already said earlier in the ama
the mass of a particle is how much
energy it has
at rest and if it's moving faster
if it's not at rest then it has more
energy so you can think of the mass of a
particle as really
the minimum amount of energy it takes to
make it
so low mass particles it doesn't
necessarily take any energy at all
to make them that's why it's easy to
make electromagnetic fields
because they're associated with massless
particles uh every photon
has some energy but there's no lower
limit on what that energy could be as
the wavelength gets bigger and bigger
the energy gets less and less
whereas with the higgs boson it takes a
huge amount of energy in a very tiny
amount of space to create even just one
higgs boson and it decays away very
quickly
so just writing down the equations the
higgs is exactly like every other field
but in practice it's very hard to push
it around or notice that it's there
lee foucher says why is it the people
who live in rural areas tend to vote
republican and people who live in urban
areas tend to vote democrat
um that's a good question i did a whole
podcast on it if you want to talk to
will if you want to listen to the will
wilkinson podcast
uh or if you did listen to it and want
more information he wrote
you know a mini book about it a very
long paper that is linked in the show
notes for that podcast
you know any question like that is hard
to answer there's probably many many
factors that go into a lot of things but
will tried
to do a little psychology right he
compared people in urban areas and rural
areas
on measures of the big five personality
inventory
and he made claims like there were
certain uh big five personality traits
i'm gonna forget what they are so i
shouldn't try to reproduce them here but
some personality traits naturally go
along with living in urban areas
others with rural areas and those
personality traits also to some extent
do line up with political affiliation so
maybe that's part of it you know roughly
speaking
people in urban areas are more
comfortable
in uh kind of an environment where
there's new experiences going on all the
time you know you go to
your favorite ethnic restaurant you know
there's different languages on the signs
around you there's people you don't know
and all that stuff
whereas people in rural areas are more
comfortable with
knowing what's going on like knowing
what kind of food they're going to get
at their local restaurant and it's it's
sort of
comforting that there's a routine that
is predictable they don't need to sort
of worry about getting things wrong and
stuff like that
and neither one is good or bad but it's
very natural that that would
line up both with where you live and
with how you vote that makes sense to me
iric says i have a feeling the answer is
no but have you ever played the
video game the outer wilds i completed
it
more or less the same time as listening
to last week's time travel episodes and
it strikes me as a perfect example
of a time travel story where you're not
necessarily trying to change things
so no i've not played it nothing against
playing video games but i have not
actually gotten into that uh
i was look i was an og video gamer like
i went to the
spaceport and played all the uh
asteroids and lunar lander and space
invaders and i had a little atari when i
was younger
but you know the video games are so much
more sophisticated now
and i part of me worries that if i got
into it it would suck up a lot of time
and i have other things to do so i'm
trying not to have that
that possibility be presented to me
tim kennedy says in your biggest ideas
of the universe number 22 cosmology
you talk about the universe having no
center in a thought experiment if right
at the time of the universe was the size
of a grapefruit there was one cubic
micrometer right in the middle of the
grapefruit
and another on the outer edge of the
rind wouldn't the first be more in the
center
than the one that was on the rind uh
well there was never any time when the
universe was a grapefruit
it it when we talk about the size of the
universe and again this is totally our
fault when i say us
i mean you know popularizers of science
we talk about the size of the universe
we usually mean
the size of our observable universe so
as we've already said in the ama
we don't know whether the universe is
infinite or finite
okay even if the size of our observable
universe
was the size of a grapefruit almost 13.8
billion years ago
the universe itself might have been
infinitely big at that time
and it's certainly at least you know
again as far as we know
it was not that there was matter in a
grapefruit-sized
region of space and then empty space
outside
that's conceivable you can imagine that
but we have zero reason to think that's
how it was
so the universe could be closed let's
say it could be
the three-dimensional version of a
sphere and then it could literally have
a finite size and that size could be
that of a grapefruit
but it wouldn't have any middle there's
no middle to a sphere because
when we say in math or physics when we
say the sphere we mean the surface of a
sphere so the surface of a
two-dimensional sphere has no middle
what you're thinking of as the middle is
inside and that doesn't count that's not
part of the sphere
and the universe could be a
three-dimensional version of that so it
could be a closed
positively curved three-dimensional
manifold
that is spherical in its geometry but
again no
nothing in the middle so that i think
that the thought experiment starts from
a place where we don't actually think
that applies to the real
universe andy val says
why do you do what you do is it is the
quest for knowledge and understanding
enough to keep you fulfilled along your
journey
or is there some greater goal you're
attempting to accomplish
um so i presume what you mean by what i
do you know professionally
um in the broad sense of you know
including talking about science and
doing podcasts and things like that
um you know look i think that
any answer to a question like that that
doesn't start by saying
because i enjoy it is probably not
completely honest right i think that
very few people uh do things that they
absolutely don't want to do but they
think it serves a greater goal
you know most people get personal
satisfaction from pursuing
greater goals so i think you know i do
enjoy like
i mean figuring out the universe
thinking about it doing science and
philosophy
and you know talking to people in other
fields in biology and neuroscience and
design and cooking and uh climate and
all these things
is just enormously fun for me not
necessarily for everyone and that's also
cool and so you know i like
learning new things i like being the
first person in the world to figure
something out for the first time
and i like figuring out how to say those
things
and then saying it and i like talking to
other smart people who
have learned things and are talking
about them i don't know if you can hear
caliban
meeping in the background i don't know
why he's meeping right now but uh
certain times of day they want attention
and they just got fed so
caliban wants pets right now but i got
to finish the ama
um so you know just like a cat i have
things that make me happy caliban would
like to be petted right now
i like figuring out the laws of nature
um you know
that naturally fits in to greater goals
to
have a complete understanding of the
laws of nature to
make the world a better place by
spreading both knowledge of science and
an appreciation for a certain
way of apprehending the world and
learning about it and
being kind to each other and all those
things but
i think that if i attached a greater
goal to it it would be exposed facto i
think that you know honestly
the best answer to a question like that
is i'm i'm doing it because i enjoy it
and i enjoy it a great deal
peter whaley says what advice would you
give to someone who wants to enter the
world of physics i already graduated but
have a thirst for knowledge about our
physical world how can i know if i'm up
to the task especially on the
mathematics side
um you know there's the only thing you
can do is try
right you apply for a job you know doing
physics
is a weird thing because it depends a
lot on what kind of physics you're
trying to do like you know my
familiarity is with
very theoretical speculative kind of
physics right not applied physics
and so the kind of physics i do
basically every single person who is
employed doing it is almost
always for university sometimes for a
laboratory or think tank right the
institute for advanced study or fermi
lab
or someplace like that but that's it
that's a very small number of jobs so
it's hard
to get these jobs but there are plenty
of physicists
who are in other areas of physics that
are much more applied and are much more
useful
to the outside world uh who work for
industry
or or for the government in some other
capacity um
and there's an even larger number of
physicists who learn physics and
do something else with it whether it's
going to wall street or working in a
completely different
sector something like that but i have no
idea
how uh you know your particular
background or anything like that
so yeah apply for the jobs is what i
would say
if what you want to do is write physics
papers
then you know uh try it out write some
physics papers
um put them up on uh i don't know reddit
or quora
and say like what do people think about
my physics papers you know it's it's
very easy to fool yourself into thinking
you have a great new idea
about the world um but you need reality
checks you need other people
people who are in the field and have
been following it
and uh just ask yourself this
you know every morning on archive.org
there are dozens and dozens of papers uh
appearing being written
right is there one
category within the archive whether it's
you know astro ph or
hep ph or whatever where you
number one can download those papers and
read them and understand them and number
two enjoy doing that
if those are both the case then you're
probably good enough to
create some of your own if that's not
the case then i would concentrate more
on
learning more and catching up rather
than trying to create new physics
yourself
william e clark says you say that the
best mathematical description of the
universe we have is a
that of a vector in hilbert space why do
we need the whole hilbert space
when just a single vector describes the
whole universe well because
the universe at a single moment of time
is described as a vector in hilbert's
space but then it evolves
in time the vector changes to a
different vector so we kind of
need at least as much of hilbert space
as
we would have to let the vector which is
the state of the world
right now change over time that's the
only reason
james hancock sorry i shouldn't say
that's a little bit cheap that's not the
only reason
um we very very often care about
subsystems of the universe right
so it's not just the whole universe
which is a vector in hilbert's space but
subsystems are parts of hilbert's space
and
since we almost always deal with little
parts of the universe one at a time
rather than universe as a whole
knowing the mathematics of hilbert's
face more generally is an important part
of being able to do that james hancock
says
i just found out that no one has ever
measured the one-way travel
time of light and thus we don't know if
direction has an impact on its speed
could it be that the speed of limit of
light is relative how would this affect
our understanding of relativity
um you know look as i've said before in
these amas
whenever a question is of the form you
know could it be
that something is true the answer is
probably yes it
could be um if there are
no observational consequences of that
fact then i'm not sure why i should care
and if there
are observational consequences of that
fact then i suspect we would have known
a long time ago so
i haven't thought very deeply about this
particular phenomenon
um so maybe there's something i'm
missing here but it's
it's not something that i personally
think of as
an important question that is open to us
in relativity right now
michaela chan says do you podcast with
your eyes open or closed
my eyes are open right now cause i'm
reading this question but so something
about your reply to lisa feldman
barrett's request to do so
suggested to me that you might usually
interview eyes closed
uh nope i don't know what i said to give
you that impression but i don't think
it's true
my eyes are usually open you know if i'm
thinking hard about something i might
close my eyes for a second
but uh generally when i'm doing the
interviews my eyes are open
um just fyi when i do the interviews um
you know i
i if in a perfect world i would do the
interviews in person
you know and in fact uh i tried i used
to try to do that
a lot and here is the downside of that
that you know if you try to do it in
person you go to someone's office for
example
um and so you can set up microphones and
so forth not everyone's office is very
acoustically good
and not everyone is good at you know
moving close to the microphone et cetera
so
even though it counter-intuitively like
being in the office
uh can often lead to worse acoustics
than
doing it remotely um all this is leading
up to something relevant to your
question so
these days i do it of course all online
and again i tried
uh since i believe that being able to
see the other person is actually really
helpful
which means that your eyes better be
open uh to the conversation right like
sometimes you'll notice in the
conversation
um just because of delays in
the internet and so forth like one
person will try to ask a question and
talk over the other person it's just an
inevitable consequence of the technology
we're using to do these interviews
so there was there is a
service called squad cast that lets you
do
interviews with video so not recorded
they don't record the video it's just an
audio recording it's still just an audio
podcast but they let each other
each of the two interviewees see each
other on screen
but squad cast just turned out not to be
a very workable solution for me for lots
of reasons one of which was
you could only use it with google chrome
i think and guess what not everyone has
google chrome so
these days i'm just using zencaster
which is purely audio
so this is the long way to get to a
relevant fact to your question
i could do the interviews totally eyes
closed because they're not looking at me
i'm not looking at them
but no i do not tend to do that
alexander cordova says i just watched
the podcast episode with neda angle
heart
and find myself to still be confused
about the initial premise of the black
hole information paradox
namely why it's even a paradox in the
first place why do we exactly do we
insist on the fact that information must
be conserved
so i don't like calling it a paradox
actually i call it a puzzle
but the reason why you might expect
information to be conserved is because
that's what quantum mechanics says
if you believe in the many worlds
interpretation of quantum mechanics and
you believe that there's just a
schrodinger equation
where there's a wave function that
evolves as we say unitarily
which is a fun way of saying it obeys
the schrodinger equation at all times
then there is a that's a consequence of
that that information is conserved
so it would represent some kind of
violation of the schrodinger equation if
black holes
turned pure quantum states into mixed
quantum states which is what
hawking's calculation seems to imply
uh now maybe you need to modify quantum
mechanics or maybe there's a different
version of quantum mechanics that's okay
but then extra evidence accumulates if
you try to invent a theory
where in our uh tangible reality
information is not conserved that
information conservation tends to ruin
lack of conservation tends to ruin other
things
uh energy is not conserved and other
things like that
quantum coherence is lost bad things
happen
and finally you know we have the example
of the ads cft correspondence where
it is clear on one side adscft is a
relationship between two very different
theories one is just a quantum field
theory without gravity
one is a quantum gravity theory that has
black holes in it
and on the black hole side the black
holes can form and evaporate
and on the quantum field theory side you
can just use the schrodinger equation to
evaluate to
evolve the quantum state forward in time
and so information is conserved in that
theory even though it's supposed to be
exactly equivalent
to a theory where black holes are being
created and then evaporating so there's
lots of sort of
indirect reasons to believe that
information is conserved
none of that is 100 certain right so
people have absolutely taken seriously
the idea that information is not
conserved
but those options don't seem to fit very
well with other things we understand
about physics
oria biddle says sam harris spoke with
judea pearl about cause and effect and
asked him about downward causation
emerging phenomena like minds that
abstract and have causal efficacy over
and above the physics of things
he stipulated that abstraction must have
causal power because the software the
government's behavior can be platform
independent
pearl said he didn't think about it in
top down terms and as an engineer he was
more interested in the clash between the
two levels of description as a means to
programming it into a robot
i would like to probe your philosophy
around this area of emergence downward
causation and their relation to
artificial intelligence and
consciousness
so um that's not really an ama question
or yeah that's like
uh a whole several podcasts worth of
discussion
you know roughly speaking um
i don't like the idea of downward
causation
i think that it is overused to simplify
things
while to to cheat around some things
that could be better described in other
terms i don't even really like upward
causation in a very real
sense i think that you know if you have
levels of description of reality there's
a level where it's all quantum field
theory
a level where it's chemistry and
molecules a level where it's people
and planets and chairs and tables
i don't think personally about the
relationships between those different
levels
as being causal ones i think if you have
a well-defined
level causal efficacy happens within
the level not between different levels
there are other relationships between
the levels you could have superveniance
relations you could have explanatory
relations
you could have coarse graining relations
and things like that
emergence relations obviously but i
don't think the causation is the right
way to think about it not in the sense
of you know
cause and effect that jaya pearl would
ever care about
so that's the very short version there's
subtleties there
lots to think about my own ideas are not
completely settled but that's what
that's the short
version okay the last question for this
long ama
is from clint ottmar in light of the
covid
vaccines coming out soon will you be one
of the first in line to get one
or will you wait some period of time to
see if there are any side effects
and if you do wait how long that's a
good question an important relevant real
world question
i don't think i will try to wait long
the question in some sense is how well
do you trust
the people who've been testing the
vaccine so as you know
from previous podcasts vaccines could
be good at killing off the virus but yet
also have
bad consequences down the line um so you
have to be careful it's not just a
matter of making the vaccine you really
do have to test it
um there is it's perfectly
sensible in my mind to worry that they
will rush the vaccine
right it's also perfectly sensible to
worry that the vaccine
approval process will be too slow
because we're just not used to moving
quickly
so i have no idea where to come down in
you know are they rushing it and
therefore being sloppy or are they being
overly careful because they're in a
bureaucratic mindset or whatever
um but i suspect you know
that probably it will be fine and anyway
there will be a much better place when a
lot of people are vaccinated
uh with a good vaccine which i hope that
they're gonna get
and you know i i have no idea also
you know what the process will be for
people being vaccinated like
uh do you just sign up and go to
walgreens and they they shoot you with
it do you have to like uh
get in a queue uh it's certainly gonna
be a rush when the vaccines come out so
i'll be perfectly honest i am not
someone who follows every in and out
of that particular process um
it's one of those things where i judge
that it's crucially important to the
world
the vaccine the coveted vaccine but it's
not something that i personally
have special understanding of or any
influence over myself
therefore i'm going to wait for it to
appear and at that point i will try to
judge whether it seems
reasonable to take it or not my
suspicion is it will be reasonable to
take it and safe
i haven't really dug into that very
deeply so don't trust me
on that particular issue other things
you should absolutely trust me on but
that one
i would i would do your own homework and
find some reliable sources that's what
i'm going to be doing myself
hopefully next time we have an ama
everyone will be vaccinated and the
world will be somewhat
back to normal that's probably up over
the optimistic i think but you know
that's okay
we can be optimistic um good no no
new ama coming out at the end of
december so
but anyway if you have holidays i hope
you have a good holiday if you don't
hope you're hanging in there 2020 will
be over see you on the other side
[Music]
you